Game four of the 2018 World Chess
Championship match the first with an
American player in decades world number
one Magnus Carlsen played a new opening
against challenger Fabiano Caruana but a
slight hesitation on his part led to
quick equality and so far the shortest
game of the match with a day to rest at
the match still tied the tension
continues to build game 5 action live
from London coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to today in chess
world championship edition and as you
see we're in a Sicilian Avenue right
outside the venue in London as we see
these two incredible men at the top of
world chess and facing off in a
much-anticipated match we have American
challenger Fabiano Carolina and the
reigning king Magnus Carlsen so far the
match is deadlocked with four draws
that's two points for Fabiano who lives
here in st. Louis where we were
recording this show and two points for
Magnus I'm Jennifer jihadi and I'm here
with my master yasser sarah wan to cover
around five of what rates to be an epic
match it's certainly shaping up that way
it's been fantastic all the way through
Game one we saw the best chances and
they belong to Magnus Carlsen
but when fabbi saved that game ever
since neither player has even come close
to getting something serious against the
other and it's one of those things that
with each progressive draw the tension
in the match really keeps ramping up and
up and up almost a skins game is going
on here from golf to chess but let's
take a look at our format and catch up
with the blade well here's the basic for
those of you who are just joining us
this World Championship match is best of
12 games so that's the first player who
gets to six and a half wins we've got a
luxurious a three part time control no
drawers before blacks xxx and a prize
fund of over 1 million euros and also
keep in mind that 32nd an increment for
every move you make you get 30 seconds
bonus on your clock and that was crucial
once again in that game one where fabbi
was living on the increment that's right
and our schedule check well our schedule
we're in round 5 out of 12 as I
mentioned take a look ahead and you'll
see you that for the Americans watching
this turkey and chess November 22nd
that's a Thursday that's Thanksgiving so
you can argue with your family about
nothing except for chess and whether
you're on Team Magnus or team Fabi but
exactly I think most American families
aren't keen favi right of course of
course you got it yeah and you only see
the tie breaks on those days in case of
a 6 6 tie that's right in November 27
that would be the type read a if the
match is indeed deadlocked but I don't
know I mean that there there's obviously
the more drugs we have the higher that
likelihood is but I still really like
Rex's prediction he came on a couple
days ago and said three decisive games
right what's your feeling about when
we're gonna see that first decisive game
of the match yesterday I thought that by
the fourth game we would have seen our
first for sure I think that Rex was
right in terms of his prediction of
three decisive games but boy we're
beginning to question that judgment with
each passing draw Jennifer well today
we're gonna move soon man but I would
like to point out that normally we throw
two maurice at this point but Maurice is
still on his way back from New York City
where he was on The Daily Show with
Trevor Noah and boy did he kill that
interview it was a great promotion for
chess he talked to Trevor about why
chess is so that was my favorite part
about why chess is so important for kids
exactly and the training that goes into
it and you know what how a child changes
Maurice is really an ambassador for
chess and he Maurice was explaining that
one of the things that he sees in
children is they began to think about
their opponent and elevate their
opponent because kids all about
themselves I want this I want that I
want understand who's boss in the house
but it was a brilliant performance is a
great interview you can watch it on
YouTube it's quite funny as well so
anyway the point is Maurice will be a
little late today because actually like
a beautiful snowy day here in st. Louis
but we're Christmas Day we're pleased to
announce that Grandmaster Jessie cry
will be filling in for the first couple
hours Oh brilliant really a very
interesting grandmaster who's gonna
bring lots of fascinating perspectives
to this match and the four games that
we've had so far yes I all look forward
to him another thing we're gonna have
for you in the hour is Christian korilla
who is part of team Carolina Grandmaster
recent cover star on chest Life magazine
for winning the national open a very
popular guy here in st. Louis where he's
often a grand master in residence and
often does a piece for us the counts
corner I think we have to ask him ever
attended a the cat's corner in London
Abby's team he certainly doesn't want to
give anything away and of course we are
today in chess and we have world
championship also going on in the ladies
in can team in sense they're down to
their final four and the amazing thing I
think about this final for Jen is that
three of the ladies yes that's right
we've got you and Jun reigning champ
Alexander coaster nuke former champ and
we've also got Maria musici so the last
position standing is also a former
women's world champion her sister Anna
who's actually even a little bit higher
rated than Maria right was knocked out
by Costa nuke in the rapid playoff and
then Katarina la noveria hydrated but
has not been champion herself but in a
way the surprise in a 64 planar knockout
like this is that there aren't really
any surprises he has is usually dress
you usually expect that on cinder
exactly but here the cream is rose to
the crap these great players we've got
reigning world champ Grand Master Zhu in
June 27 years old from China she's part
of the women's Olympic team that won
gold medals this year and she's also
played in some of the winter classics or
just the classic norm tournaments here
in st. Louis so it's a nice to see her
face in the quartet
potential champions Alexander Cristina
has also played here in st. Louis the
new mob homes actually Alexander breed
ambassador for the game she won the
Women's World Championships almost a
decade ago and a few years before that
she was actually vice champion when she
was still a teenager so she's still
quite young but she's been around for a
while fighting for this title it feels
like it what a great veteran she is and
then and another former world champion
that's right for the 2015 Women's World
Champion one of the famous sister duo
musici despite being the lower-rated of
the two she has a chance to actually
clean two World Championships before her
sister so something for everybody to
brag about in this family as exactly a
very very accomplished family indeed and
finally we've had Katarina Lana 28 years
old from Russia very high rated BC 2556
probably one of the highest rated
players female players to never won the
world Women's World Championship except
of course the one and only Judit Polgar
who has never won because she never
played right but I think Katarina is
also also among the top rated and I kind
of a second win for Katja because you
see there she had some really wonderful
successes in the early 2000s is the
European champion and now you know this
is a real real opportunity to but look
we've got to say hi to Jessie
that's right Grand Master Jessie cry
he's joining us in a surprise hello
yeah you know I woke up this morning
like every other chess fan I had some
coffee a little breakfast I had all my
screens and I was just oh it's gonna be
a great game I'm just gonna sit here and
watch it and then I got a call that
Maurice is not coming in and they said
can you work maurices big machine yeah
and it's kind of intimidating to even
touch this thing is I think Maurice is
the only one who knows how to drive it
so I'm gonna do my best to kind of fill
in oh really yeah we've got moves
we've got another Rasul Eva you know
considering that fob Fabi did not get
anything from the first two whites or
especially the first way right now I was
thinking that he might differ and
Kramnik had a similar opinion right here
we go he's going for the rascally bow
again but what's different Jessie well
let's start right here right actually
this position g6
so when Yasir and I were kids the idea
of just hacking immediately on c6 just
didn't seem to make much sense like why
are you doing it unprovoked then I it's
not hurting anybody so that became like
really fashionable for decades and
that's been going on for a while and
Fabi played that way the first time now
let me just say also would mean yeah sir
we're kids this moved the wind gambit
yes was very popular and I like it
honestly it's very dangerous you can
also kind of do it against the French
sometimes like you can do it like d6 d4
d5 and then at excuse me excuse me I
blew it already let's move back efore be
six how does it go Knight of 3d v e5 c5
and 94
yeah and in both cases what you're
trying to do is steal the black center
pawn and especially in a position like
this you really see that you can play a
3 or B 4 now is it it will be impossible
for black to get as counter play against
the d4 square so that's kind of like the
positional basis for this win gambit
that we have here and I don't think
visit never been seen in World
Championship chess so I'm really excited
about this game a huge advantage to Fabi
to play a dynamic move like this because
you know you can do the computers but
you can also play it out with your team
and see what are the human moves what
are the typical things humans are gonna
do with this and then check that against
the engines so I'm really excited about
this game going forward so far the most
exciting opening of the match no
question about that I recall very
vividly the 19
ninety-two match it was a rematch
actually between Bobby Fischer and Boris
Spassky from sveti stefan and belgrade
and it was game 11 where Bobby played
this before but I just can't recall
offhand if it was the exact position the
fact the game the day but what I had for
lunch was really confusing right now but
okay so we have a repeat of the
rasa-lila with Bishop b5 and in the
first two games immediately there was
this capture on c6 Bishop takes c6 d
takes c6 and away we go Game one was a
terrible outing for a B this time he
deferred the capture castled immediately
and after Bishop g7 rook e1 again
deferring the capture and just as Jessie
was saying this knight on c6 isn't
scaring anybody if the what Knight wants
to move to d4 that's okay we'll just
trade and why did you move the same
piece twice so Magnus wants to get back
into his usual routine with the movie 75
he's basically saying go ahead please
hurry hurry please make this trade and
let's get back into the lines of play
that I've analyzed now this for me is a
real stunning gambit move like I say and
as Jesse was saying the wing gambit this
move b2 b4 is known in a number of
openings even like him I'm gonna say an
Evans gambit you know you throw out an e
a beef or shot now here I think it's
extraordinarily courageous considering
four draws and you know what kind of
preparation has to go you go through
this you sit down with your team and say
okay guys you know like am I gonna go
for it do you
want me to put my whole world
championship ambitions on a wings gambit
is this the thing to do and your
teammate all you know gleefully nodding
their heads socket yeah you suck it up
and you go okay let's do it now let's
try to figure out what it is that fabbi
has anticipated and I think we have
Knight takes d4 on the board right
Knight takes d4 on the board so I mean
well what's it all about it's about you
know trying to take advantage of your
superior development and rip open the
position so something is natural of c3
let's say right Knights God had dropped
back I don't really see any choice
and it's all about opening up lines D to
d4 like some game really famous game
that Jews are played in 1988 in the
Olympia that she won with her sisters
right yeah where she like please this
Sicilian yes where she played like the
Queen takes f8 move at the end yeah and
it's hard for me to when she's doing
commentary in London with Anna ruled
officer mentioning that game is
beautiful it reminds me of that where
she won a brilliant sacrificial game it
was similar structure was also like a
Rasta Li mo with E 5 and C 5 and right
and a move like d4 and d5 kind of
further the point you're saying that
after for instance C takes d4 here right
C takes d4 here I got a pause because
yeah means like this 83 come to mind I
probably take it nonetheless also I just
wanted to point out if you take this
pawn I would love when I was a kid I
loved the max Lang attack and I love the
Danish gambit
okay the Danish gambit where you
sacrifice whole all kinds of ponds for
fast development and in a Danish gambit
this pawn on c5 would never be on c5 it
be on the much better square c7 so this
would be a huge
huge advantage for white so now the
question is after d4 and I'm gonna turn
it over to Jesse for his thoughts but
after d4 what's as black you're looking
for safety Jesse what's the safest way
to play this game that's right and in
that line is very typical of what the
kind of thing we're gonna be looking at
here and let me just back up and let's
show people the Evans gambit please
additional position from from the very
GetGo from the very GetGo this is
popular in the 1800's do it from move
1.e4 e5 Jesse yeah everybody's with us
okay so this is the standard most right
in their defense
yeah so there's this is the greatest
this is the most old-fashioned
principled way to play before in any of
these things
Gary's played this move as long with all
these other old world champions and it's
going to be interesting for our game to
think about what do you get with b4 well
you get time right and now we're gonna
hit them with c3 and we're gonna get
time and there's many different moves
that black can play here but we want to
play d4 and we want to bust open in the
center before he gets a chance to
develop that's the key idea now in some
ways I think what you can say this
position has been analyzed a lot maybe
about roughly equal but the position
Fabia has I think is better and let's
just contrast it for a second when we go
back let's start at the beginning to
this move here white is black is wasted
a tempo with E 5 a tempo with eat
obviously 5 still there but G 6 is the
bishop really correct on g7 it doesn't
look like it right so for all these
reasons this looks like a better version
and so instead of in the Evans where he
takes with the Bishop it's a very
similar you take with the night ok now
we get it this development move Bishop
b2 here
so c3 can still come we still want to do
the same idea which is to bust open the
black position
here's where it got its gonna get really
wild though okay Magnus says I want to
take you out of your preparation and
play this funky move a6 and Bobby said
you know what you're I'm still in my
prep I'm still in my prep buddy we did
this we did this all night long and now
a3 so it is I think a better version and
if I'm not mistaken like the problem is
like you go back knight c6 I think who
then we take it and then we can take e5
why not our pawn back we're super happy
and we're up in development the whole
thing looks pretty good if you play a
bee a bee this doesn't look good that
again kind of like the the wind gambit
that we first showed in the Sicilian
that c5 pawn doesn't really want to move
out of the center so this is a terrible
position I think for what will complain
you the line for a second we see a trade
of rook yeah sure and just go ahead and
take that pawn on b4 and it's air into
our audience why you think those triple
pawns are terrible yeah so we can ignore
those pawns they're not going in we can
snatch them up any time and here you
have very pleasant choices between
things like Knight takes e5 and even
maybe d4 but Knight takes e5 is a simple
way that you might have to be careful
with a bishop I see finally because a
6-5 was playing right so let's look at
it this is coming fast and furious and
let's go to the game position and my
instinct was that a takes b5 was not
correct
86 b5 a takes b4 both on the board yeah
so we are gonna get this I think this is
not only better for white but this is a
position where black can really have an
accident
half a team Bobby right because those
pawns in the B file are going to fall
and were up so much time in this
position black needs to play Knight f6
and castles and in the meantime he also
has to play d6 at some point to get out
his bishop we have a huge time advantage
and in that time advantage we can decide
to win
ie 5 pawn we can decide to go after the
be pawns it's going to be a luxury
choice as we like to say right a choice
where we have many different plans where
we can do things where we have no
there's no danger for white
there's no danger for white no danger
for white I agree wholeheartedly Jessie
one of the things that's been happening
in this match is these guys they're
their defensive ability is so
extraordinary they keep shutting each
other down so continue your analysis if
you were right rook takes a one right
Bishop takes a one you're very very
pleased with white I get it but go ahead
and play the position after d6 now I'm
happy you said yes sir because I was
like yes there's a pawn grubber but not
C takes me it's gonna be six and that's
got to be the right move right and and
one thing that we saw a little bit in
the laceration is it might be a little
difficult for us to actually snip on e5
but I don't think so
so for example it takes takes if we play
Knight takes we have to worry about the
pin exactly right we can't play Bishop
takes though and is that what we want I
assume so why not
Bishop tags let's look at it you yeah
you were saying that black needed to
play Knight f6 and get out of Dodge as
well right so go ahead Knight f6 with or
without the bishop trade by the way but
go ahead Knight f6 and you know if black
you know it's so annoying if he just
gets in one or two right yeah well
leather bet that that single opportunity
of advantage could slip away that's
developed with attack right that's a
good move they told me to develop with
attack when I was a kid that that was in
our in our opening books alright so if
we defend the pawn with Bishop to d7 I
assume something like Knight c3 is gonna
come exactly there's even moves like
Queen e3 oh that's interesting
I'm hitting the pawn and maybe touching
a gas the anointing yeah yeah
now I'm in trouble and I don't like it
if you would take the position back
before the move Bishop takes e5 Jesse
yeah you as White had just recaptured
your pawn yeah Phil there's no question
you had an edge yeah Phil's my only
question is is how big is it go ahead
play Bishop takes e5 if you will please
right and this time Knight f6
immediately no trading the bishop so
again white black is one move away from
saying I'm untouchable
oh yeah SL and I'll be safe so how do
you how do you increase your initiative
and one thing I think we should say
that's kind of interesting about this
position is the other games with the RO
Salim Oh blacks you know the
compensation for his troubles was it he
had an unopposed light-square bishop
right and he still has that in this
position so even if I think way black
could think about is to say all right
even if this gets really bad and I even
lose a pawn as long as the position
opens up and that Bishop turns into a
hero then I have some chances so suppose
white plays d4 in this position sure you
could DD for in the d4 Trey and I love
to develop so I would be looking at one
of these Knight moves right you know
rips no yeah looks good 95 is possible
and maybe even on Knight c3 you don't
even want you know the human move would
just be our castle you can have my pawn
and let's play a game where I have that
on a post Bishop and indel actually
it'll then become a technical challenge
I mean White has to be very happy with
the opening if I was that way right but
it will become a technical challenge at
that point by the way we do have D 6 and
D takes e5 and B takes e5 rather so the
players like we might have by edging up
to this for this game on the board yet
the players are catching up to us we've
seen that rook trade and we're
anticipating the recapture and this is
where jesse has been playing Bishop
takes e5 well you also mentioned ideas
of night a3 and 93 but I like restoring
the material equality
then after Knight f6 so we're looking at
take sonson c5 Jesse and I wanted so now
he's like we immediately took back when
c5 maybe a little hasty okay and black
should definitely consider playing
Knight seven the drawback there is then
your be pawns are permanently weak but
you are saving time right and you're not
going to lose the e5 pawn directly well
your what you want to move closer to
Castle five you point out bringing that
Bishop into nice concert with the rook
on FA right is a problem after ninety
seven isn't there can't can't I be my
pawn grabbing best Queenie to a move
Jesse pointed out a moment ago as well
you Jesse you're saying those those can
become d6 all of a sudden exactly you're
saying those be pawns double bound
horrible right that might be hurtful but
this the night um be ones greatest fear
in life though is to see the pawn appear
on b4 and I think on Queen e2 you got to
worry about b4 because then the knight
can't move and the genius then of the 97
is he's dominate at the moment with the
pawn on e4 but he's dreaming of coming
to c6 right that's that Night's Dream
this is what Yass likes to follow three
results game I'm not sure no no it's
initiative I really really really do i I
mean I mean the question is is you know
when white went for this from the very
very start he was in this gambit mode
and though it was played by the way
right we've seen 97 on the board so
we'll see if this Queen e2 or take 76 is
played right but as we were saying yeah
yeah but white was in this gambit mode
of looking what update your position
sure this is the position at the moment
I want to take I want to exploit a lead
in development right so I in this line
that we were just looking at and Jesse
was explaining that the nightmare
scenario for the knight on b1 is
it would we would remain forever
hampered here after this move d4 it's
like I'm I'm purposefully trying my best
to explode the position as quickly as
possible to exploit whatever lead I have
in development is it you know a serious
concern or not and that work that's
where it takes calculation and that's by
the way where the engines can really be
of help
sure though I think the human move you
know it's funny that you know Yassir
likes to talk about grabbing pods he's
not there second all the fabi's because
the easy human move after 97 they say
let's bring the dog and see what happens
right you know let's bring it in I think
you know the problem is going to be well
black has many problems here he has to
decide which paws he wants to defend and
which ones he wants to give up in order
to Castle that's right and Queenie to
before by the way have been played Oh
considering the fact that Magnus is
obviously caught unawares it seems like
he's playing relatively quickly while
Fabi by contrast is playing instantly I
think and that is here's the question
for the panel how much of this is
preparation of Abbey's a hundred percent
9 percent 100 percent when will attack
us chest tweeted some pictures of Magnus
at the board and all of his questions
you know Magnus is turning out to be
like more like Gary Katz browsin you
might have originally members before you
created really yes like some awesome
facial expressions yeah but people who
are following along jesse pointed out
that when he watches he has also in one
screen he has si on another screen
that's the big computer the best neural
computer super right in the world we
have one comment that magnus has played
all obsessing moves so far so i don't
know i mean obviously i can't i don't
imagine he had this all prepared but
he's just
and calculating everything correctly
despite that how extraordinary is that
that's a that's extremely extremely
impressive one of the things is it's so
very very hard to catch these guys
unawares why because that's all they do
is they prepare prepare their opening to
great great lengths so this move be for
I thought man that's a really really
really courageous move and the idea of
catching Magnus unaware and then he
turns around and he throws the very very
best counter blows at you quickly after
Queen e2 is also play oh that's oh now
we have Queen to c4 on the board oh man
a little a little slide nuance there not
the Queen v5 check that was the knee
jerk moved the Queen c4 say hello to my
preparation talk about that move for a
second was that in the engines choice
top choice well you know I believe the
engine if I was you know I didn't like
Queen e2 did not like Queen e2 but I
think we're gonna know when Fabia is out
of his prep when he actually tapes takes
time to think okay because in any of
these positions you could say to
yourself if you're white and you're like
this is great this is as good as it's
gonna get and now I'm gonna find my plan
my way through this forest and at some
point he is going to do that for sure
but at the moment we are playing very
quickly and you know Fabi often times
when we look at the computer with his
prep it's not it's not what the computer
recommends right he has his own way of
dealing with the computer and helping
the computer find its own dangerous
moves let me get an update here and
Queenie to by the way the idea is that
they kind of met the kind of annoying
attacking move it should be six met by
Queen b5 check and suddenly the the pawn
on b7 is hanging but what about the
pinning move Queen c7 just attempting to
regain c5 oh you have just Queen takes
b4 there or I'm still coming to grips
with it
so yeah it's a weird moment but sorry
Jesse just for you to kind of finish
your thought was Queen c4 or well your
first of all you're saying Queen e2
really wasn't right uterus arising also
I don't feel it's yeah I was about to
say it wasn't the human move but Yassir
played it as he wanted to grub so Knight
c3 felt very human even though it was
the computers move let me just say
something totally obvious I'm sure
everyone knows this already but I just
want to say it in all the other games
black one the preparation battle
absolutely and now by playing this
offbeat thing Fabi has won it and now
it's suddenly on White's terms and
that's one of the ingenious things like
even if we thought this was a slightly
incorrect opening in a way it's still a
very potent way to play chess
just get a position that you've analyzed
your opponent doesn't know it is a
brutal situation and it's terrifying for
the other person because they feel like
and Magnus really has this fear of not
playing Fabi
but playing fabi's machine exactly right
I imagine I would love to play Maurice
some blitz games but do I want to play
him with this machine no part of that
right yeah now I just want to be honest
I do not understand just by looking at
it firsthand what Queen c4 is about what
Queen e2 Queen c4 when I look at the
position I'm really concerned about my
knight on b1 but I think yes there's
good the other thing when I was looking
at yassir's variation of Queen b5 the
night at least had a dream of playing d4
Knight d2 night c4 and here I don't know
what the nighttime be ones dream is yet
yet we're gonna find out to me I haven't
looked at the computer but the natural
human move would be knight c6 right that
would be the natural move to me and here
let's look at what the computer says
okay the computer saying d4 as before
yeah so yes there's a pawn grubber but
look at this he knows these ideas right
takes d4 right and then Knight takes d4
right and it's kind of a hassle right
this is kind of a hassle exactly so
let's take a look at what he says well
first of all let me just see what's
wrong with the natural castles right
we're gonna snip everything off right
everything's gonna come off and we grab
a pawn we grab a pawn and our night um
be one now has beautiful yeah
entry into think we need to kill the
pawn on b4 that guy has to go and says
what that did so that's a useful human
variation just to see what's going on
right of course Magnus is thinking about
knight c6 less because because okay take
the move knight c6 back for a second aha
and Jennifer had a very intriguing
suggestion that I really hadn't
considered I was kind of like you let's
get out of Dodge yeah she said well
Queen c4 strange let's try to turn the
tables on the knight play the move Queen
c7 and pinned that pontoon to whites
Queen how does the engine deal with well
move you got to get rid of this pawn
right and then I'm assuming pawn takes
why have you played Queen takes than the
pawn on e5 would fall clear right so the
Beast says check to the misérable King
okay and that's not to worry about now
is another nasty check here I got a
block the check again as well yeah time
for the night time for the night this
feels like a comfortable position fixers
but this is a seven but this is to
Jesse's point that and I think
especially it was game to where Magnus
was really worried that he would be
playing against babbies computer is
and he wanted to avoid preparation so he
didn't play that move Knight d2 remember
that was that rook da game right
declined but yeah which you poo-pooed is
a terrible movie yeah I fab II but it's
really really true at the world
championship level how you know
preparation where the chess engine has
really gone to do great depths right
I'll put it like that
right and I didn't see the move Queen a5
did we know and I know one would this is
truly a madman's move and let's think
about it just before we get into the
engine because it's about to get really
hairy right okay so the bishop on a1 is
hanging at pawn on d6 is hanging right
and so when you think about it well this
is the natural move and now you're gonna
have to do something fancy to get out of
that and I think the fancy that es plan
is to develop the bishop here however
look at how oh I don't know it's getting
kind of spicy here you know I don't know
how I feel about this kind of thing the
computer thinks maybe you know it's just
a slight advantage for white which is
amazing how that vet frayed Queens
you know maybe maybe Carlsen had
something like this truly like prepared
it's hard to imagine or looked at
something similar because these moves
are coming it's so sorry
well right it felt like he was thinking
and it just doesn't feel like something
you'd prepare for actually famously I
think it was fiddler beat Kasparov in
this Bishop b5 thing and Kasparov said
something like well why would I ever
prepare for that right right and this is
even on a whole nother level and it's in
a way though it can make a certain
amount of sense because Magnus before
was always playing a 45 and now he's
going to switch and so his team's gonna
be like we're gonna cover all the
sidelines right so something like this
you know he wouldn't have been as they
wouldn't have been as in his mind as it
is for fabi's has just looked at it
maybe he looked at a month ago or a week
ago something like this but right he's
some kind of memory because this looks
very tricky this is
definitely accidentally create Queen a5
quickly as that right variation because
this is yeah a tightrope tyson this is
double double edged okay that's cool the
mainstream news is actually following
the games yes oh he mocks st. louis says
after four straight draws st. louis and
Fabiano carolina lands a surprise blow
in the early stages of Game five
I mean it's just sort of like Walter
Cronkite stopping the nightly news to
say enough about Vietnam in record big
Bobby Fischer the Queens gambit declined
to take an early lead in the game and
they got it right I mean you got it you
got to give credit to mainstream during
then they get it right it's amazing it
sounds like a chess player wrote that
tweet yeah okay so queen a5 Jesse and
Leno let me try to say something about
this variation that I think is what this
is what Magnus sees because it's I don't
know what else to do for white you take
the pawn right this Bishop is force now
remember your Bishop over there is
hanging
I beg your pardon why is the bishop move
force white why is it mix why can't he
just move his knight let's say okay okay
I take it back you could play the
nightmare I mean whose gambit in now I
mean we went from a pond down for white
because do look at that move that the
bishops still hanging but yeah oh I see
you want to go deep yeah we're gonna
yeah oh my god this is I don't think
this is what you I just thought I just
because I'm not a grubber I was just
like Bishop e6 has got to be the move
but yes this maybe he's thinking about
this what I was gonna say though yes
sirs with Enix yes what you're gonna
what you can force is black is is you
can force an endgame and which is a nice
bailout whenever you can force a nail
and ending it kind of feel better about
yourself
now this looks very dangerous for black
and I you know just first blush I have
no idea what's going on but notice the
pawn is still on b4 okay as long as the
pawn on beef is
there and before black can endure a lot
of suffering because that night is like
out and the bishop on a1 is honestly
also a little shut out so not so simple
to see how to play this particular
position even though you know obviously
with this beautiful pawn you're doing
great but you've got two pieces that are
poor and this would be hard to play like
the engine wants to do rook d1 that's
kind of hard to find
and then obscure isn't it and then you
got a you're doing your move d4 that's
that's the idea
yeah thing to do 7 d4 right right right
whoa well this is amazing stuff and Fabi
has taken the pawn on that six that's
the question Jennifer did he capture he
did indeed so the current position is in
fact this one after Queen a5 attacking
the bishop
fabbi ignored the attack to the bishop
play takes and now basically Magnus has
one of two moves only the Bishop e6
moves the one you were advocating for
Jessie right or knight c6 engine's
choice is yeah by far like it's not even
close kind of thing or is it a close
call yeah sometimes the engine is like
that yeah it gives you two possibilities
and it weighs them equally well right I
think I think 96 is insane yeah well
what a game so far guys yeah finally
you're getting an exact position it
seems from his preparation and putting
magnets to the test but Magnus has
played Bishop to e6 relatively quickly
so insane is not on tap today this
morning and yes let me just get your
personal like human take on this endgame
position that we're getting but let's
say we get this position it seems kind
of forced it's my right
so with human eyes as white I'm I'm a
little concerned for him for white Oh
for way
because I don't see you know like it
seems this is this is the things that I
fear you're here like I'm gonna win I'm
gonna lose my c7 okay right and my B one
night is terrible right so I'm gonna
lose my big trump on c7 and then how do
I go from there
right and even it you know if I find I'm
sure a human is gonna find something
like the rook d1 v4 thing but then my c2
pawn is weak you know there's other
problems just positionally so I'll ask
you yes just what's your human take on
just looking at this position well
exactly well first of all to echo what
you're what you're just talking about
there one of the things that I was
really really shocked as I became a much
better player and I played against my
first Grandmaster and I was really
intent on getting into the head of the
Grandmaster to understand how he thinks
versus how I was thinking and what you
just articulated jesse was a whole
series of worries right I'm like wait a
minute I'm worried that the pawn on b4
is keeping my knight at bay I'm worried
that the bishop is artificially isolated
I'm worried that wait a minute if I lose
this pawn on c7 maybe the pawn on c2 and
that's how grandmasters think they worry
about you know like what could go wrong
so the first thing I wanted to say is
that when my opponent surprises me with
a move like before what fabbi has and I
find a way to steer it into an endgame
it's like oh I feel relieved that you
know like I'm not getting crushed okay
so it's very very clear that black is
not in danger of getting crushed anymore
and then the question is can white
actually achieve an advantage and for
all of the things that you've just
articulated I was about to say if I was
white I'd start to pull the emergency
cord myself I'd start beat I'd start
thinking not necessarily about rip D 1
and D four but something like Knight g5
king d7 because you mentioned it korean
masters hate to play against the tube
ships especially an open a position so I
might take the bishops off but having
said that I'm giving up what I would
think would be hopes of an advantage
right so this is just extraordinary to
me that despite being unpleasantly
surprised Magnus has steered the game
very very well and by the way what is
the current position is it Bishop e6
Bishop e6 and stop right here this is
what we have Jennifer is there an
alternative I don't where else would you
go well you got the engine okay you're
running after Queen a1 your threat after
takes on e7 you're running just
checkmate
okay well I mean if you if you want to
take the bishop sure I'll threaten the
checkmate oh and and Knight c3 will be a
tempo so I reckon you'd probably go
night-night c6 for instance and okay my
bishop really is genuinely threatened
now and golly I don't like too many even
Queen a soother you gonna go a ship c1
there's a disturbance in the force right
okay this is not the harmonious stuff
that fabbi wants I kind of reckon Queen
c7 is forced right I don't think there's
a real genuine alternative and that's
when we get this ending this is where
the computer likes rook D 1 and D for
and massive swap trades maybe white
could even start with c3 but I think we
can talk about more of a neat
position right then advantage advantage
white and let's just actually keep that
c3 move on the board okay because that's
a kind of a Union move if you will
because it highlights another worry of
mine and that is that that the unopposed
light square bishop is just gonna
dominate all my stuff and when you play
c3 you know you weaken the light squares
especially B 3 and C 4 and maybe in a
worst case scenario d3 in fact he might
display b3 there right yes well let's
leave that by maybe well okay for the
moment the c7 pawn still lives right I
mean don't let that pawn remain on the
board too long right so so yeah b3 b3 is
probably too much too ambitious yeah but
the thing is that all those light
squares are weak in another variation
let's say he plays this rook d1 move his
first thought you wanted me to go back
not to play the move season right c3
does we can look at see if he doesn't
feel right to me though okay the right
to d1 yeah that now that's also happy to
worry suggested move yeah right you're
also gonna have to worry at some point
of Bishop g4 and isn't that gonna be
annoying either now or later you know
it's like oh man in games 1 and 3 games
one we saw fabbi playing h3 because he
was worried about Bishop g4 in game 3
Bishop g4 actually appeared on the board
that's right and there was a trade on
the f3 square here Bishop f3 have a has
even more to be said for it but wait a
minute there's C eight equals Queen so
Bishop so now right so not right away
you're gonna have to play King d7
because it because this would be highly
embarrassing yeah do to allow the pond
to promote with yeah but one variation
could be like King d7 yes see for and
then a simple move like Bishop g4 really
I think so thinking of my word so really
well here's a strategy for for black to
say I want to get rid of all of your
pretty pieces and leave you with the
bishop on
or the night of e1 and the bishop on a1
I just want you to get rid of all that
stuff
my rooks coming into a8 my King's gonna
take your pawn you know for example
let's just
you could play d5 you could play de but
let's just look at the pawn grubby move
exactly King takes I'd rather be black
now now would rather be black because
this rooks coming to a8 to talk to these
terrible pieces in the terrible c2 part
just continue the position for a second
Knight B 1 - D - lets get the let's get
the pieces off the first ring yeah you
know like let's do something good for
white for a change so I can take the
pawn if I want right you can recapture
there's no question about that
okay Bishop takes on e5 now if you I
guess the consequences of 95 Bishop d1
knight c6 there's Bishop there's a that
rook e8 is always a just you're saving
Savior okay but here I'm thinking
White's a little bit better h3 nice go
ahead and you know you you said you
wanted to leave me with the ugly pieces
yeah right now it's okay I don't have
too many uglies on the board it's about
isn't your King ugly my beautiful King I
don't have a monarch I don't gonna have
a game yeah but okay this is this is
better
well at least is not dead so pause
between the two scenarios that he looked
at maybe not this exact thing but
something similar or maybe this exact
thing like Ward that he's just coming up
with all the best moves and I should say
this is how I've got I've got a good
story for you but go ahead Jesse Queens
that has happened and you know I think
this is gonna be a very difficult moment
for Fabi unless this is somehow prepped
I think it's a difficult moment because
black is really close to being even
better he doesn't deserve to be better
because our positions been so beautiful
for so long but this is the moment where
for example in last game game for Fabi
had a very nice position and then
drifted okay alright and I'm worried
that there's gonna be some drift here
too so this is a difficult moment with
moves you could consider d4 rook d1 he I
hope he doesn't play h3 but that's a
thought he could play yessir c3
I like the c3 move yeah yeah I just
wanted to say because you asked a very
very good question there why why does he
find all these good moves and I remember
talking to Hendrik the father Magnus and
he was telling me the story the very
very very young Magnus like think a
little bit toddler four five six year
old Magnus and he had gotten Magnus this
kind of game set where it was countries
of the world a kind of a jigsaw puzzle
as well as the capitals of the world and
he thought okay this would be a game
that Magnus could play for months and
months and months and months and you
know did it that a Magnus kind of put it
all together and he said I was bored
that okay give me another game it was
like no no no no this was really fun
and what what Henrik realizes that
Magnus not only knew where the countries
of the world belonged on the jigsaw map
but he also knew the capitals of the
country is like it went into his head
and it just stayed there and he said oh
dear I've got an amazing son who has
recall and when you see these types of
crazy positions with b4 and stuff like
that I remember a lot of Paul Morphy
blocks and they would show all of these
old guys playing these crazy romantic
attacking lines right well in truth I
soared to those games but I forgot most
of them like the immortal game right
yeah I mean you kind of see it and then
you kind of like could I replay it
absolutely accurately if I was forced to
maybe but for the most part you forget
it
but Henrique is basically saying Magnus
doesn't forget these crazy offbeat lines
that he's so great exactly incredible
memory anyway somewhere in the back of
his head it's there yeah it's
extraordinary because knowing that he's
gonna play with ninety-six looking at
before at some point and whether it was
before this round or many many weeks ago
right somehow something's very similar
to this or this coming up exactly you
think that's more likely than him just
figuring it out all over the board oh
yeah I don't see this as like improv I
mean no and especially the fact that he
played it relatively quickly
you can't think on fabi's time because
Bobby's playing instantly exactly I mean
it's really a fascinating question it
really begs the question then though if
he does know this why I think for any
time at all why not play as quickly as
Fabi because he knows it but it's not as
crystal clear as Fabi since he was the
one who was surprised right it's like
one of those things where you kind of
like okay let me get I know what I'm
doing but still let me get into the Zen
at the moment let me make sure that I
have my recall is accurate and
everything else I this is not a position
I would play quickly by the way Jessie I
do believe we have C 2 C 3 on the board
Oh trying to get rid of that b4 pawn
which you've been oh I didn't like C 3
and inlaid it's been played oh I had
this whole variation this whole computer
thing where the pieces white pieces made
sense and now c3 have well you we have
to give you props there c3 then didn't
feel right to me because of all those
light squares okay that's why I didn't
feel right to me
I'm gonna guess you terrified me with
that pawn on b4 I wanted to get rid of
it did it but you reckon King d7 well
yeah let's get rid of the pawn let's try
this out and then I guess White's gonna
activate the rook Black's can activate
the
rook Bishop c3 is an ugly square but I
don't know where else you want to go
really mmm Wow I'm you put me on the
spot there for a second
because I I'm I'm debating between 93
mm-hmm actually and even perhaps b5 but
93 you would take the pawn back on
before I look yeah and I think the drama
here's what I mean by the light squares
because there's an octopus square
exactly you for the night there yeah
morning I don't want that night coming
in oh yeah that's too much okay but
continue the lighter unfortunately
there's a back rank mate I was thinking
of roof on e 1 2 B 1 and again my pawn
on c7 is still alive yay and
unfortunately I'm not threatening
anything that's the problem with my back
Greg problem right I have no well maybe
Knight b5 is it right you know this is
this is a computer move that of course
no I wouldn't have found it but Bishop
c4 is ignoring everything and planning
to play Bishop d3 to make your rook move
Wow yeah that's cruelty this is exciting
okay just let's have some fun and
continue the line h4 h4 h4 lift
give me Lori octopus time oh no you were
supposed to put the bishop well if you
made it look that was the idea I'm gonna
play vision before and the bishop is
also controlling this Knight d5 stone
right that and the knight is like all
these octopuses are really deadly
because they take away your rook squares
yeah they're really cruel okay continue
night David five I guess you gotta take
you can't let her on on c7 left you
better take that and then will dominate
the night
oh you're not even gonna take the pawn
on c7 that's he's my friend that guy's
gone
yeah he's gone okay and here I'll give
you dose absolutely I would prefer a
much prefer blacks position here right
so I you know c3 is on the board Magnus
is thinking about it right I'm gonna yes
I'm gonna guess this the first move
well I don't know he did play it kind of
quickly okay he did maybe he just felt
it had to be played but those light
scores really worried and if I could ask
the question King David seven and of
course you saw instantly I took upon
yeah what about D to D four right that's
that's more to the spirit maybe yeah
that's what I'm thinking so well we can
take once and what did I why did I do it
you have these nice Center pawns but the
pawn on b4 continues to dominate the
poor Knight rook a8 92 92 yeah and since
this pawn is pinned it's a no and really
do anything so I don't know just
something like rook a to uh I can't play
d5 because like you're saying the bishop
on a one lacks protection and this is a
great example of the two bishops they
are so strong it's also an example of a
position where the black King is more
active than his white counterpart the
black King is doing all kinds of cool
stuff and the white king is a victim he
owes us a tempo for aloof move like yeah
sir made in the last not married right
Wow impressive stuff Jennifer jump right
in bail me out if you've got a good
route I need a partner
Jesse's taking me down so far we have C
three on the board yeah C three is on
the board yes sure let me do let me let
me update my board I apologize and by
the way I think we have a resolved in
the game between you and June and
Causton York I do believe that custom
you lost but never mind c2 c3 and this
is where jesse is saying look this move
King d7 essentially black is playing
with an extra piece because this King is
doing good things in
capturing upon White's King is being a
kind of like a helpless victim and the
rook is coming quickly to the a8 square
and here's our lady's update Jennifer
and update indeed you and June who has
not had to play a rapid playoff yet that
seems to be the big edge area that she
defeated coasting you no doubt exhausted
from an epic rapid playoff yesterday
against I don't lose a Jew right I think
that's just a huge edge of course you
see that time and again drew Andrew and
beats Irina and I'm not saying that gets
that three days he wouldn't be a
favorite anyway she is the highest rated
player remaining and the first game to
right you know that it's and in those
matches where the nerves of those
tiebreaks
can be so exhausting I mean that's all
the differences I mean that can make the
total difference as to who will win the
competition and now we're taking a look
at whether Bobby's gonna go take some
before play for d4 we do have 287 okay
after C 3 King be 7 and yes and now it's
White's and this is g4 but as we get
sink into this rich end game that is
well prepared by Fabiano Karen and well
met by I'm hagnes Carlsen
there is okay a quick break and be right
back with more from today in chats and
our special guest a grandmaster Jessie
cried welcome Jesse thank you
yeah absolutely amazing for the chest in
the u.s. he came extremely close two
years ago to winning but Sergei played a
great tournament and he also deserved
and he played a great match against
Magnus but this time is Fabiano's chance
yeah I mean it's definitely very
exciting it's the first time that the
United States has had a challenger in
over a generation so the last challenger
was Bobby Fischer that was quite a while
ago
it'll be pretty exciting to see if he
could return the throne or if he can you
know challenge Magnus and be able to win
because I would think Fabio Khurana has
definitely had some very strong
performances over the years so you know
he's definitely a very good Challenger
for Magnus
um I mean Fabiana has been playing quite
well so he certainly has chances I don't
think he's anywhere near 50% contrary to
what he said but that being said Magnus
he hasn't been that impressive of late
and he also isn't playing that much so
it's it's hard to tell what what sort of
shape Magnus is gonna be in but I think
more than anything it's it's gonna
really depend more on the quality of
Magnus play than the Fabiano's Blake's
if Magnus plays up to the level that
he's capable of I think his odds are
probably 85 90 percent but that being
said Magnus he's he's had some ups and
downs and certainly his match against
Sergei was far tougher than anyone
expected so so it'll be interesting
interesting to see yes of course I max
I'm excited that's like American players
playing yeah I think it's very
interesting like you know let's we'll
probably boost popularity of chess in
America for the tournament for the
candidates tournament I was predicting
Fabiano
I was hoping Fabiana would win and I was
also predicting that he seemed the most
likely and obviously he played great I'm
really
be that there's an American playing for
the World Championship which hasn't I
mean I've never seen it in my lifetime
so it's gonna be really exciting
obviously it's tough he's up against one
of the best players in chess history but
I think if anyone right now has a chance
he's definitely one of the few guys who
has a chance against Magnus I mean it
was amazing personally for me because I
know Fabiano and you know I was watching
his game I was following the tournament
very closely I was just glued to my
computer watching the LAT last game like
I even though I knew he was winning
until it was done like I just couldn't
stop watching it I think it means a lot
to the u.s. because it's been so long
since we have someone competing for the
world championship title I think it'd be
amazing to have a world champion there'd
be a lot more interest hopefully
there'll be a lot of more mainstream
media coverage so Chen just can become
more mainstream and people I think Bobby
Fischer is like a household name so it'd
be really nice for if I beyond that to
become a name that people in you think
of chess and you can't say oh yeah five
beyond the Quran he's either challenging
the world champion no Houston you want
champion I think it's great that he won
the candidates and he's gonna be a play
for a while chess champion because like
we haven't had a American like chess
champion for a long time so I think
you'd be really nice to see someone from
the US actually win the title and it
could be like Bobby Fischer again well
it's definitely really exciting that
avianna is the world challenger and even
people who don't play chess know they
know and they ask me questions they go
have you heard about that no yeah and
he's actually from simply snow so we're
really proud of him and now to have an
American World Chess Championship
challenger I mean that's huge you know I
mean I was following the candidates
Horton with a lot of interests and I was
very happy to see Fabiano win and for us
to have an American challenger and it's
gonna be great for tests because it's
gonna be you know the number one number
two players in the world playing could
be really great to watch
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
United States the st. Louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant Central West
End has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique nonprofit
institutions the Chess Club and
scholastic Center of st. Louis is
recognized as the top chess facility in
the world and plays host to all major
tournaments including the u.s. Chess
Championships and a Sinquefield Cup one
of the strongest chess tournaments
globally tournaments are broadcast
online to more than 150 countries led by
an expert commentary team of
grandmasters the Chess Club is an
educational organization committed to
promoting the game of chess with a
specific focus on bringing the benefits
of chess to children throughout the st.
Louis area research shows children who
play chess exhibit improved analytical
skills and increased confidence the
Chess Club is highly engaged with the
local community bringing scholastic
chess programs to more than 100 schools
providing hundreds of classes each week
directly across the street from the
Chess Club is the world chess Hall of
Fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the US and world chess
halls of faith cutting-edge exhibitions
feature rare historic chess artifacts
paired with world-class art innovative
programming explores the intersection of
chess art and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries the world chess Hall of Fame
is nothing you expect and everything you
love three different galleries and a
premier gift shop highlight the culture
history and creativity behind the game
come visit play chess leave enriched to
learn more about the st. Louis chess
campus visit STL chess campus org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome back to our coverage
of the World Chess Championship underway
in London Fabiano Khurana playing with
the white piece of this game and I'm
working a bit of a surprise but Magnus
is so well prepared met it fittingly as
and what if there what's your impression
of the position now that we have on the
board after we were left at the time
before move 18 where Robbie was deciding
between seat takes before and other
options he did play he takes before
Magnus quickly played of rook to aid and
reply what's your take I'm just amazed
anything that you can get in this
preparation you can really hope to throw
off your opponent as did fabbi you take
this courageous approach you put this
great prep together which is equally met
well met this is like dork of itch and
Federer you know just two great great
players playing in against each other
each getting the right measure of their
opponent we analyze this position with
Jessie a moment ago I played Knight c3
and quite frankly I got a poor position
Jessie had recommended to me the move
Bishop c3 as the proper way of playing
and with great reluctance I'm gonna have
to accept your advice there Jessie and
do that yeah well that's because the
alternative didn't work out very well
right what would happen after Bishop c3
all right good sir so the rook is
hitting the bishop and let's just say
it's very uncomfortable if the bishop
goes to be two which would be the
natural move because honestly you don't
want to go to c3 you're just in the way
of your knight right so but the problem
is then you're just inviting this friend
in he's angry he's an angry he's not
friendly he's not friendly
so Bishop c3 and you know this is a good
example of chess principles the computer
likes black just a little bit better but
you know let's just say some obvious
stuff let's take off this part
and here's where my principles differ
from yassir's let's say something
obvious it doesn't look like it but why
it's actually a pawn it doesn't look
like because his pieces are so funny
why do I like black I like the better
King
I like the unopposed light square bishop
for black I do not like the knight on b1
the knight on b1 makes me sick up to my
stomach and you could tell Yassir did
not want to play Bishop c3 no one does
and that's what fabi's thinking about
because you played Bishop c3 and you get
a knight like that if you want it's a
bad business in fact one of my big
moments as a chess player is talking
about this when we were commenting the
other tournament was I played some game
and I also I was a pawn grubber like
like Yassir and I had a friend and we
are analyzing he said Jesse I'm real
serious he was angry at me never let me
see you have a knight like that again
and right no I'm not gonna have that
night I'm not gonna have it and that's
what you're doing when you play Bishop
c3 it's a real clunker of a move you
know so but what are you gonna do if you
give back the pawn on b4 it's hard to
see how you're gonna contain the black
pieces and the past be pawn that's what
it looks like - yeah so it's a pawn
Jennifer by the way I wanted to say we
have a very very special guest
Christine kerela is on the line welcome
to the show Christian hi guys how are
you good how are you doing in London
Christian doing just fine doing just
fine suffering from the cold or
suffering from what from the cold not so
much I'm quite used to the cold but
definite you know as a second is is very
very difficult to watch the games
because you know you work throughout the
day and then and then you hope that
you're going to get some rest during
during the players games but in fact you
just simply cannot do anything else but
watch the game and it's a nerve wracking
of course it is so nerve wracking
Christian I'm sure especially in Game
one when there was like the time
pressure situation could you watch or
did you have to close your eyes like in
a spirit let me tell you let me tell you
one thing that was the only guy
I fell asleep that was the only game I
fell asleep and I woke up right after
the time control when he played queen g7
and Fabi got some some drawing chances
so I didn't go through the massacre
before before that so I was very happy
well thank God for your heart experience
all the painful palpitations Christian
with each progressive draw it seems like
the tension is just you know ratcheting
up and up and up how is it as a train or
a second do you feel it in your gut and
what are you guys doing to deal with the
stress to be honest it feels like a
tournament of course each and every
round is more and more tense but at the
same time we're taking it one one game
at a time and it seems like Fabian who
is doing exactly that you know I cannot
feel the tension I cannot see it on his
face he's handling it quite well and you
know we we keep him busy
he's his training he's doing a lot of
sports I you know I I'm happy with what
he's doing
very good give us some more kind of mood
beginning mob for autographs before and
after the game do you have to be double
as his bodyguard we're trying to shield
him from those type of things of course
we're not we're kind of in a bubble we
don't speak with uh with pretty much
anybody except yeah you know you're
you're special
Thank You Christian well you know
Christine usually we have you on the
counts corner if you were gonna do a
Count's corner or in this game what
would you talk about oh man well it's
it's it's a difficult position to uh to
assess I think is very close to equality
but to be honest I I have a feeling
Magnus right now is having the pressure
especially because of the bishop air
I cannot lie to you and say that I'm
happy with with the opening outcome but
it is what it is and you know
Fabiana will have to shield some
pressure and then go through the storm
and then potentially equalize the game I
don't think he's going to have much
problems doing so it's incredible how it
seems to me that Fabiano's cataratas a
mental game is so strong things don't
really seem to get to him he seems so
tough is that something that you think
he was born with or is it something that
he really worked on as well as
specifically for this match
I think Fabiano is a very streaky player
and this past year he has been going
from success to success I think the big
difference was was made when he when he
beat Greece sugar in last year's match
he was going down and then he turned it
around and he beat one of the best
Blitzen and rapid chess players on the
planet and I think that was a huge
confidence boost and after that he just
kept on kept on winning and kept on
winning and the way I see him right now
he is extremely confident he believes
that you know he can take this title
away from from Magnus so you know I'm
very happy with his psychological
condition at the moment I don't think
he's doing anything in particular of
course he's doing his yoga he's doing
his sports and those help but I think he
just needs those victories and he's
getting those victories he's his owner
streak and I think that definitely plays
into his good form every second day
Christian you get almost 48 hours off or
any of those hours actually restful I
mean you mentioned yoga I know that when
Bobby famously turned it around in the
candidates he saw the shape of water
before the movie yes are you actually
having any fun in those rest days or is
it pretty stressful no absolutely
absolutely uh you know we we work a
little bit less we go to sleep a little
bit early we wake up a little bit late
later than usual and
you know we take a lot of walks we try
to enjoy the atmosphere of London is a
very beautiful city and you know Fabiano
is having a good time in those res days
but of course there is a lot of work
being put in his preparation as well is
he recognized or by random people on the
streets of London like not outside the
tournament hall just around were
recognized once at the restaurant in the
first day or something like that some we
were eating at this ramen place and some
guy just came to us and he said that
we're here from France you know
we're supporting Fabiana and so on you
know all the nice thoughts and that was
the only time we got recognized oh I'm
sure you were recognized more times when
people just didn't want to bother you
appreciate it and when he wins the bads
then you're gonna need to up that
bodyguard to him
you know again I don't want to get too
much into your prep or anything like
that but Christian for me as a chess
grandmaster I'm a little bit stunned how
ineffective the players both players
have been with the white pieces and how
black is I'm not gonna say been
dictating but black has been having an
easy easy time as that come as a
surprise to yourself I mean I don't
think that's going to be the case for
all the games of course you know a lot
of players nowadays they focus
especially when on their black openings
just to feel secure and then you know
with why do you have a bit more mobility
so you know I think Magnus's team has
has put a lot of work into his black
repertoire and it shows and you know
that's that's what we want to see we
want to have a very difficult challenge
that's what we're getting right now so
we are all enjoying it but I'm not
surprised no wonderful Jessie I wonder
invite you in here do you have a
question that you might want to address
either - sure
well yeah Christian I guess I would ask
you just as a chess player not
necessarily the second how do you feel
about this move Bishop c3 does it make
you sick to your stomach
III move it's a difficult position
it is a difficult position especially
because of those angry bishops you know
especially the right square bishop the
knight on v1 is not looking great at the
moment he's going to have to find a way
to get him out of course if you want if
you play d3 then the bishop people on c3
is no longer going to be safe also
potentially the pawn on d3 is going to
be attacked by via Bishop b3 Bishop c2
potentially it's a very uncomfortable
position but at the same time okay
Bishop c3 ad it's it's a difficult move
to make but what else right maybe should
be too then rue k2 comes and you're kind
of forced to go Bishop c3 once again if
you go Knight to c3 then you're most
probably going to have some problems
with with a knight on c3 with a bishop
on a1 sorry but at the same time I'm not
really sure what you're going to do
after Knight takes b4 because I'm
threatening Knight c2 and if if black
manages to get the the c7 pawn as well
he's going to have a passed pawn on the
be fine and that's going to be extremely
dangerous so he is decision time for
Fabiano that's for sure it's going to
allow black to get the the pawn on b4 or
is he going to accept a passive defense
nevertheless the b-pawn is going to
safeguard to be safeguarded at least for
the moment you know you know what it's
like when you play Bishop c3 it's one of
those terrible yoga poses and he's gonna
have to hold it for a really long time
with this hey Christian speaking of yoga
there's been a lot of mainstream
articles about Fabiano and you know his
life outside the game we're and since
you obviously know if I'd be better than
almost anyone right now
were there any that you really thought
captured the man may
Stream media pieces that talked about
Bobby that you liked be honest we had
the best laugh about The Guardian piece
the one where they were mentioning he's
an aspiring film director which is
complete nonsense director that was
quite funny so we had best laughs about
that but to be honest we're kind of
shielded away from from media and we're
trying not to follow as much as possible
and especially Fabiano he's he's
definitely not paying attention to those
type of things right but uh yeah he he's
going to get that happy ending by by
bidding Magnus you know exactly script
Christian tell us one thing about fabi's
personality that has nothing to do with
Chad's that would surprise people I mean
he's he's a very stubborn guy and I you
know I guess that plays into into his
game as well um and to be honest I I
think that's a good thing but he is a
very very stubborn guy I'm not going to
elaborate on that you know sometimes you
just gotta believe in your ideas I think
it's a trait quite frankly that top
grandmasters have and they have to have
this stubbornness and this absolutism
and the belief that they have not only
in themselves but in their ideas so that
that one doesn't surprise me Christian
that he has that I did want to ask you
one other question at the very start of
play there was a big surprise in the
media center where a college house where
the event is being held
they had like a media center with 35
chairs for the journalists as they were
coming but there was a hundred and
twenty
credited journalists when you go to the
to the playing Holly you accosted with
requests for interviews than the like
are you surprised by how many
journalists you're seeing in London
there's plenty of them but to be honest
you know there's a much more important
persons than myself arrived you know
target
you know I haven't been on the European
scene for a very long time so we're in
London if the tournament would have been
in the u.s. probably I would be
recognized much more often but on this
side of the pond I'm kind of undercover
so usually what what do you miss the
most about being here in st. Louis and
this is a softball question I mean I'm
definitely not missing the weather work
is a priest no key in there as well yeah
it's a white Christmas over here you
guys I miss you that's completely
understandable Christian I feel you
there yeah
seriously though Christian you know
thank you so much I know everything it's
a really busy job that you have here our
wig team Karolina so we really
appreciate you giving us this exclusive
interview I mean absolutely we miss you
right but we know you're doing good work
out there and just let fabbi know man oh
man does he have so much support that's
right we're all world of support coming
from st. Louis direct to yourselves
thank you we're on Team Bobby thank you
all right have a good have a good one
absolutely you too guys
Jesse bring us up to date you've had
plenty of chance to really get into the
position yeah what what what are the
problems for both sides well you've been
mentioning White's problems but does
black out issues he is upon down after
all black
as a pawn down that's right and we've
had a very long think here from Fabi
okay I get it because this is a very
difficult moment and one thing is like
even if you kind of do a process of
elimination and then decide that Bishop
c3 is in fact your best move it's gonna
be very hard psychologically to play
because once you do it you know that
you're just sitting down to getting
punished for the next couple hours right
that's what you're gonna know when you
play visib c3 I want to say also that I
the feeling is we might not play Knight
c3 there might be part of his soul which
says I can never do that to my knight
I've never heard that I'm doing that to
my knight so if he doesn't do it one
thing I want to say about people
watching is it really frustrates me when
you know Fabi doesn't do the computer
move right because this is a position
where I wouldn't want to do the computer
move either it just does not look good
and even though with the computer and
you start looking that you see that
Knight c3 doesn't work which is really
the only other option right you still
want to find a way like a force awake to
make Knight c3 work because Bishop c3 is
so ugly right and the consequences are
really long-term for example let's give
up just a couple variations of how the
computer sees the positions king c7 and
then it wants to go out on an adventure
with Knight g5 okay so one thing I tell
my students is you don't want to play
with your pretty pieces you want to fix
your bad pieces and this is an example
of playing with your pretty pieces
pretty because it's the only piece that
can do something your Knights terrible
your bishops pretty awkward right and so
on a move like this
you've black is free to have various
choices Bishop c4 keeping the bishop
that would be my first thought but you
could also do things the computer say in
things like Bishop f8 or rook a4 giving
the bishop why because that night was
like whites only good piece and a simple
way to think about chess is if you have
you're playing against an opponent's bad
piece you want to trade off all the
others and that's kind of a thing that
Fischer invented at least I would
through his games I was able to
understand that
and so this is really dangerous when
when you start trading off everybody
that's bad imagine you're a bunch of
guys and you're going out on the town
and there's one ugly guy like me it's
fine if there's about like 20 of you but
then when there's only two of you I
start to really stand out I don't look
so good right now and that's kind of
what it's like when you try to start
trading the pieces that are good right
and so 95 the computer suggestion
another move that I wouldn't like to
play so it just shows you like playing
the computers move not necessarily
something that humans like to do to make
the position ugly this reminds me of
Game four with fabbi
go ahead that that position that you
have Jesse I'm sorry
yeah that it went Bishop c3 King c7 95
reminds me of Game four were fabricated
in my opinion a really good move B 7 B 5
and the idea behind that move at the
time he played it was simply to fix a
pawn on b4 which was being guarded by a
bishop on c3 when black plays the move
b5 stupid or whatever it is however
you'd like to describe the move right it
just said it does say hey look for the
long term
go ahead play Knight takes c6 why else
did you play Knight g5 by the way and
guess what's left just what you've been
exploit extrapolate the ugly pawn the
ugly King and the ugly King and on black
side of the board the only thing ugly I
add I see is the bishop on g7 once it
goes back to f8 yeah it's gonna be
heroic right so I see a lot of pluses
coming out of this particular variation
for black absolutely and and part of the
problem is once your pieces are funny
like this it's very hard to start doing
anything active you know a [ __ ] Bishop
c3 is telling yourself in the world that
I'm just gonna try to hunker Tao and try
to survive this so I want to play a
little bit more actively yeah would
allow just in this moment
I would like to try or essay the move
rook on e 1 2 c1 I'm kind of bluntly
hoping for a trick against the king on
c7 I want to play you know to capture a
pawn on e5 or to play d5 they say d7 but
I could play b6 too but let's try d7 ok
can I get in the move b5 let's try it
out let's give it a shot
we're coming in 94 I see and once again
if I take on d4 with the bishop this
time and I play d3 at the end I'm
dreaming of 92 I'm thinking if I can
just get a knight yeah yeah yeah rookie
yeah okay it's not the end of the world
yet rook e1 okay um oh gosh it's really
but it is getting it's very frightening
is this this pawns gonna be hard to hold
Oh terrible it's terribly different
right but I do have 92 I'm like one move
away from being okay I mean I'm on the
edge yeah there's a precipice of
something bad happening you know in the
came to decent that's really simple
right just going after the pause before
always on the menu trading trading off
the rooks
let's go ahead and look I mean yeah yeah
the line continued the line oh man so
now you're gonna it's two knights versus
two bishops but you'll get the past beep
on and I will suffer terrible yeah and
this is starting to turn into the dream
position oh this is the dream position
for the tool anything like maybe 500
could continue the line that I wanted
yeah III King c7 rook c1 that was okay
King over and this time instead of b5 as
Jennifer says let's start with D
to d3 my I'm trying to get my knight to
d2 and to c4 and then I'm out of the
woods and one nice thing about it for
black is he has a variety of moves its
like whites the one who has to play
precisely rook a to looks good to me
here yes there's b5 look at that boom
just say long-term I got that stupid B
four points yeah keep it right yeah
Jennifer thank you Jesse so issues for
happy for sure but Jennifer we have a
phone call from New York hello turn your
TV off and ask us the Gustav oh sorry
oh yeah any other I am to my two
questions but my first one is I
dysmorphic Genesee and vyasa's if they
were around at the time when Fischer was
champion I don't even think Jen was born
yet but you think it's gonna be a no
wins that it will be the same the same
euphoria I won Fischer won the same room
to chess so he thinks it because the
fish's personality has a pretty dynamic
kind of guy he more or less you know
brought it onto himself once it was the
Soviet Union against the free world and
my second question is have been feeding
at the Women's World Champion
ship the same timing thing as the men's
would it make more sense they had it at
different times so people can watch both
if they wanted to I think my questions
would be yeah thank you - very very
excellent salient questions
unfortunately no should fabbi win the
World Championship it would be great for
chess it would be a phenomenal uplifting
a rising tide and all boats being lifted
but it was just a simply a different era
it was the Cold War era Bobby was Bobby
completely unique it was totally
front-page news
and massive massive coverage it would
just be great for American chess but I
don't think you can say before you would
be the same but I don't it's very
negative because the way that they're
asking it you're gonna get a negative
answer absolutely at the same time what
about all the amazing things are
happening in chess now that wasn't
happening then the green infrastructure
we have online the interiors in fact the
we actually have a new world champion in
United States passionate now that you
brought it up check this out that's
right every year or it's the underage
but that's based on the age of January 1
and so we've got an eight-year-old Raj
Jenner Eddie from Illinois and he
actually cleats a gold medal get this he
went nine out of nine in the world under
eight championship clinching the gold
medal with an entire round affair
congratulations to Raj and he's part of
the massive us chess delegation in
Santiago Spain sponsored by two sigma
and it's just incredible he's actually
coached by Costa Kabuki as well as Minsk
and Abhinav who's his main coach and was
like working with him on skype in the
mornings and they both said this kid
just loves chess super nice kid
I want to sign him up to a management
contract right here right now all I ask
is lifetime earnings and in other chess
news we had a high at the top of the
table of the Shenzhen chess masters but
it was MVL who won on tiebreak / jury
and Bing Lauren just incredible all the
events going on simultaneously the
second caller I mean the color second
question was about why the Women's World
Championship in the world over at the
same time speaking of all these
overlapping events and I do agree I
think that that suboptimal because of
course the women therefore get less
attention I mean just think about the
fact that normally there would be
several prestigious chess journalists
there but now they can't be there
because they're in London clear which is
giving them not quite as much attention
as they deserve but we're very proud
that we're featuring their games and
some of their graphics here on the today
in chess
that said I'm I'm really excited about
the new direction of women in chess it
seems like a few days after getting
elected York of it just made it an
announcement for a very positive change
for women
he didn't mention actually the overlap
as much as the prize fund and the
structure of the event okay but we got
to go back just a little bit about the
Conti World Championship for ladies and
the fact that you and Jim won the World
Championship in a match earlier this
year the problem was was that there was
a scheduling problem before that so it
kind of like dominoed and pushed the
Women's World Championship matches into
a situation which we have it's a overlap
hopefully that will be corrected we
won't see this type of clash on the
calendar which is very injurious by the
way not only do the players themselves
and organizers but also the journalists
because the journalists would like to go
to these World Championships wherever
they are around the world that's their
duty that's what they do and you know
they're there they don't have the option
they really do have to go to London in
this case indeed so great questions oh
thank you those questions are very very
good on on point and Jesse back to you
have we seen the move Bishop c3
reluctantly played or otherwise right
yeah reluctantly played he thought a
long time and to his credit let's call
it his human credit after King takes c7
he has not played Knight g5 the computer
move which like I just didn't feel right
it doesn't right so he played the human
move d3 which you we were kind of
looking at an important difference
between the variations we had we were
just went around c1 is a rook c1 your
rook will be loose after the bishop on
c3 is traded so on he won the rookie one
threat won't be such a big deal if some
kind of Knight d4 later happens as was
one of our variations we went rook on e
1 2 c1 at 1 turn that's right and then
brought it right never I'd it right back
we lost the clean
d3 is a superior choice right and so the
intention is clear we want to fix this
night and any good player is gonna want
to fix their bad pieces black now I
think Magnus is gonna think a while
he's already probably seen this position
while he was waiting for Fabi to move
the choices though I think are kind of
simple you've got b5
you've got rook a to and there might be
maybe you could no I think those are the
choices you don't wanna f6 is kind of a
natural move to dominate the knight on
f3 but you don't want to allow d4 right
you don't want to allow that and we want
to keep the bishop on g7 in contact with
the d4 square if we ever want to play
Knight d4 so your two main moves are
rook on a a 2 a 2 is so you could put
that move on there that's an option
number one that's just the active
develop your look and the second one was
this move b5 which is to fix that's
right
well the fit to fix the weak pawn and to
say my game plan is to beat you in 20
moves with queening the pawn on b1 come
hence right we're coming with that veto
on it and it's honestly white black can
win that pawn on b4 ok
right and what white needs to say to
himself is I'm gonna give away that pawn
in some creative fashion and get enough
counter play activity with my own pieces
to hold the position I think that's you
know the sensible way to alternate of
the two moves that you're suggesting me
to in b5 watch 1 which one tickles your
fancy the most in other words what would
be your choice Jesse I like b5 just on a
superficial glance level
rook a 2 would be your move if you felt
you were able to really discord innate
the white pieces so for example if
Knight BD - the problem is then I play
rook c2 and then you're just in a mess
you gotta go backing the a ship which
defends the B form and you don't want to
go back that's not where you want that's
why you play so that's the motivation
though for playing rook a to is to stop
things like that but white doesn't have
any play oh you were gonna go 90
yeah so something maybe something like
King f1 intending rookie to and trying
to fix this poor King exactly as we saw
in a lot of variations the king is
really a victim he's he's worth about
three points like a knight or a bishop
and if you don't have him in the end
game it often feels as if you're just
playing down a piece yeah you're playing
behind yeah so King f1 and what do you
want to do for black in this position I
still want to play b5 long-term strategy
you know and if you play rookie to this
for kicks let's put that on the board
where am I going I can go anywhere but
I'd really like to go to a4 and start
talking to that point and honestly this
move rook a4 after b5 that's the clean
intention to play rook a4 and then when
I need it to play Bishop f8 I can't play
Bishop f8 until I secure the pawn on e5
but I am ultimately playing just to win
that pawn and to march down the B file
and to say my bishops are much better
the unopposed Bishop especially on e6 is
a monster so very pleasant position for
black even though the computer and I
suppose other people might even still
want to claim that it's equal but in
terms of just a playing experience I
know I'd much rather be black here right
you just feel that this is a position
where black is having more of the fun
it's getting is getting a greater share
of the fun than you are and it's also a
position where if black makes an
inaccuracy there's no cost there's no
big cost
if white makes just one he has to really
hold the line here white makes one small
mistake then I think that's over you
know it's really bad ok so
fabbi under pressure according to Jesse
and the engines and he has to be very
accurate check oh let me update my well
and we got a little bit of a recap for
you and the number of moves from each
game here
remember that happen game one yeah a
hundred and fifty
as Bobby fought his way to the law one
of the funniest tweets I saw about that
was from Nigel short what the night of
Sam said that human pink Bobby should
draw the game not because of the middle
where you know he got into super time
pressure in a terrible position but
because he didn't believe in the
stalemate role talked about not being on
high side team Bobby where's the other
games were it was a if we pull up that
graphic one more time it was a the
shortest game that we saw was round four
game 434 moon yeah you see this epically
long long long marathon of the game won
a number of moves cuts down dramatically
for game two equaled in Game three and
then the shortest game of the match was
Game four we all know is fast rating for
me right you got nothing we have almost
as many moves in Game one as in the rest
of the attack something like that
combined now this is a very important
let me reiterate what what's going on
here was in Game four madness had white
right and in Game six Magnus is going to
have white and in Game seven
Magnus is going to have white so
literally from game for to Game seven
we're gonna fabbi is gonna have three
blacks out of those four games so if he
can weather this storm he's going to be
doing fine we didn't expect especially
after this move before that he might
find himself in an awkward and game
position we've just seen the move d3 and
jesse has been explaining to us that
magnus has a very pleasant choice of
rook a to the active move posting his
rook deeply into whites camp and or the
positionally savvy move bee7bea five
fixing this pawn on b4 as a long-term
weakness that black can in the future
gang
up against so two very good equally good
moves for for Magnus to be considering
and Gabi at the moment is looking at at
a bailout how do I get myself out of
this and go back to my team and say okay
guys what did we do wrong today again
it's what Bobby did wrong I think it's
what Magnus did I hate this game come on
like that was dangerous go back and
forth for a second I mean you're white
and you're coming up with this really
really crazy cool gambit like play
you're not supposed to play get be worse
yeah just because your opponent plays
good but your opponent you don't assume
your opponent's gonna play like a 3,200
in like 20 20 moves any what happens but
if your proposed to play like a 3,200
for 28 as well it's your preparation
jump in here I don't know I mean it was
a good to gamble by Bobby and he got
unlucky that Magnus played perfectly
well something went wrong for white less
likely let's revisit this is the
hopefulness that we experience in this
position
what a beautiful position if you know
what were we wrong with Queen e2 wrong
maybe Knight c3 at some point hard you
know it's it's it's like this weird
thing I think one of the interesting
things to me about chess is actually
being wrong when you're wrong it's like
this really especially here in this
position I just feel it for white but
you can see the beginnings of the
dilemma already here
the nighttime b1 is bad the bishop on a1
needs a life and so in the next couple
moves Fabi didn't fix that I wanted him
to play Knight c3 at some point right
preferably like takes and play Knight c3
here but obviously he had his own notion
so he was wrong about this position and
I was wrong as well and now we're in
this miserable business over here and I
want to say that you know even though I
felt this was worse for black averse for
white
the engines the entire time we're saying
basically equal the longer I let
maurices machine run on this position
especially with the move b5 it's
starting to say Oh Jesse I see what
you're saying this is really bad
this is really bad warming up to your
side of the argument saying white is
suffering yeah that's right that's
because you can't really move you know
like this night actually can't move to
d2 that easily because of them simple
moves like rook a3 after rook C want to
defend the bishop there might even be
something better but I'm just seeing
like also rook b8 oh that's quite
annoying as well or maybe just simply
very very annoying Jessie so when you
imagine this position is white like it's
hard to move the knight and in after b5
after a be fun and in fact like you know
you're gonna have to I think you better
bring the King in or something but the
nighttime b1 is committed he's like in
an instant he's institutionalized oh wow
he's just gonna stay there for a little
bit is you see it's so hard and you know
white is up a pawn but it's not that
significant let's call this extra pawn
the d3 pawn at this exactly and it's
just not doing that much right yeah so
you're saying that white you're saying
that white knight is not on Team Bobby
or it's actually the weakest part of
team 5e biceps yeah yeah it's it's it's
in the dorm to get into the Battle of
hammer curls Trevor Noah pointed out
Grandmaster Maresa Ashley's biceps on
the show and Maurice is back in the
house and so we we are gonna take a
quick break and get it back on the show
but first we want to give a very big
party bang Master Jesse cry who climbed
out of bed not a bad I mean I'm yeah
who's just gonna watch us over his
coffee that's right
chassé open and he came to join us in
person thank you very much it's called
call of duty call of duty and as the GM
and rest yeah I mean phone call came
Jesse
you you have responded thing and I got
to drive maurices machine races machine
that was right well yeah yeah from cue
boutique that's right right across the
way the Hall of Fame I got this tie
they're really nice yeah a lot of nice
stuff there you get you get a lot of
benefits by being a commentator that's
right well do make sure to come back
again all right right alive we got that
before we go on break we just want to
inform you've got another fireside chat
I think we're up to Michael tall oh well
we'll stay tuned because these fireside
chats are very entertaining they're fun
they're fun and we'll be back with
Maurice Ashley so yes sir the post-world
War chess international scene right its
champions exactly fidei shows up and
says well we're gonna organize this and
the age of the private World
Championships end that's precisely right
they have this match tournament
Botvinnik
wins the tournament ahead of everybody
and then that starts a real reign of
dominance for this one player no
question about it
so fidei comes into being more or less
1924 and a lot of people kind of ignore
few days at least as far as the World
Chess Championship is concerned but the
problem is Alekhine dies as the reigning
world champion
so now others have to put together the
whole world championship cycle and to
make it a continuum that constantly
succeeds so they started with the five
players for the world championship
there's like that Bob Vinick wins and
then they make these matches and the
whole candidate
and inter-zonal x' and that all of that
I'm so natural back in that time period
was all new what was over any brand
brand-new and this post-world War two
chess experience really the hegemony of
the Soviets Bob Vinick becomes the guy
Moscow becomes a capital of World
Championships played in Moscow only but
Bob Vinick is in seven of them pearly is
like home turf every time he plays
absolutely so he he he starts of course
with the twelve twelve draw he retains
as Ron Brownstein the most creative
genius ever thrown in there but we're
coming in but then we go to Smee Slavs
me Slav upsets but Vinick but then loses
the rematch and the romantic on versus
first it's a tie then and then rematch
now the rematch clause that's really
that's the thing that sticks in a lot of
people's craw hey look you're the champ
if I beat you I'm the junior I'm the
champ are we gonna constantly be
perpetually calling for a rematch
against ourselves whenever we lose but
the rematch clause is what keeps bought
Vinick in his throne and it comes to
1960 and another like kappa blanka force
of nature is created but this time
instead of this beautiful positional
exquisite harmonic play we get chaos on
some quantum level he was dropping
I should have arms on people the way he
played toss my favorite player of all
time you watch the way he play chess
nobody thought you could play chess like
that not at the world championship level
solutely and win the title this guy
didn't care about chess pieces it didn't
look like he cared about Queens even
just yeah whatever I can sack I'm just
gonna sack wanna make you the
we find out it was unsound afterwards
that he's like who cares I'm just trying
to crush you you're right you find it at
the board right what you found back home
six months later I mean I mean really
sometimes took months we didn't have
computers back then so it took months to
refute some of a sacrifice exactly it's
just absolutely criminy knocked by many
for a loop in Game one like that right
away
your French defense take that out of
here Bob Vinick switch to the Cairo yeah
this guy's crazy he's wild I can't
handle him in that and sorry going more
solid after that force of nature just
undeniable force of nature quantum chaos
tactics galore
Michael tall the youngest world champion
ever
at the time 24 years old yeah
unbelievable but because when we think
about world champions and Steinitz and
bob Bennett now you're getting youthful
now 1960 that was huge but Bob Vinick
got that rematch clause you know by
Vinick also felt like he didn't really
lose that match too tall there were some
positions he felt like he could have
outplayed him yeah he didn't start out
playing him there the end right was the
lead was so big already
they'd been overwhelmed what just was
just overwhelming and some yeah anything
magic that's like I think game six the
other five pieces and you played play
this wild Kings Indian put a knight on
that force a team you know yeah well
right ahead right and for him it was all
about what he called taking his
opponents into the jungle where two plus
two equals five right and the way out is
only one guy and so but then in 61 by
Vinick had figured it out and said I'm
not gonna play that same craziness I'm
gonna watch you and also talk a little
bit of illness as well this is the big
problem this is the big problem
Misha was one of those players he loved
the bottle he there was not a single
party that he never said no else was
doing 50 60 cigarettes a day
oh yeah and now I mean how do you do
that and pull that off in some of the
games I play with Mike
when he was smoking a cigarette taking a
deep drag
he was already lighting another one
forgetting the fact that he already had
a cigarette in his head so yeah he was
definitely you know you know carton
every two days kind of thing I know I'm
a big drinker and I remember this
hearing a reading this which is kind of
a wild thing that he had some kind of
illness I know he had RINO you know
kidney issues as well but when he have a
problem the way he'd cure it was by
drinking yeah yeah but using alcohol to
knock out whatever but he he definitely
was a darling to many the games that he
produced even after he lost the titles
brought Vinick were still fantastic his
unbeaten streak of so yeah yeah it was a
real champion but his he was really one
of those as far as the World
Championships concern meteorite is
absolutely and burn and disappeared but
left such an indelible memory who knows
no question absolutely and there's so
many stories and their each and every
one of them wonderful in their own way
two very quick ones when he lost the
world championship title his
humanitarian spoke out when he said well
now the Soviet schoolchildren are all
very happy when I lost the World
Championship
now instead of learning how to sacrifice
the pawns and pieces they could go back
to learning how to defend them and that
made them well they're very happy he was
a humanitarian - he's just a beautiful
beautiful person writer will just say
you haven't read table outbidding 1960
get it now it's a what a treat that book
right is that written by Tall himself a
lyrical book by an epic world champion I
just felt like I was right at his elbow
side when he when he played that match
and the second one is story is he's a
Moscow as his his common he's in a
hospital he's suffering something and
he's told that that night at the Moscow
central chess club Garry Kasparov the
world champions playing in the blitz
championship at the Marche
central chess club the guys got tubes
he's in the the hospital nightgown
he slips out of the hospital goes and
plays in the tournament and beats garry
kasparov well of course he couldn't
handle by vinnik bite of anything goes
on plays Petrosian loses but by viniq
had his big reign tall certainly had his
magical year and those two great
champions will never forget never
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and we are back I'm Jennifer
Sahadi with Grandmaster yasir Sarawak
covering the world championship
we got thank Jessie cry for filling in
from Maurice who is now back from the
Trevor Noah show The Daily Show - today
in chess Maurice thanks for being back
hey it was a lot of fun being on the
show we had a great time trevor is a
chess player although I did have to bust
his chops about making fun of chess
while I was on the show but we had a
great time it was so much fun being in
the green room and chatting with him and
then finally going on the show itself
that was a lot of fun I tried to catch
the flight this morning but they delayed
the flight because of the weather here
in st. Louis and so I could not get here
on time but I've been watching Jessie
definitely filled in admirably and when
I landed I was looking as like my god
look at this crazy position so I'm
excited to be able to look at this
position with you guys of course that's
right welcome back yeah I thought you
did great by the way I thought your
tremendous ambassador for chess and we
were saying nice things about you which
is pretty rare when you're not here
absolutely that opportunity to grill you
seriously Maurice I mean you missed the
this incredible opening we're doing here
when that happened I was in the air and
on one of those small planes that don't
have any Wi-Fi so I'm like biting my
fingernails oh my goodness but as soon
as I landed in a car picked me up I pull
out the phone and with the magic of
today's technology and chess to be able
to look at it anywhere you want to and I
was before what whoa and it just got
crazy the stuff hit the fan but Magnus
man this guy is a boss handle the
situation admirably and I started
worrying a little bit about Fabio how is
he gonna coordinate his pieces but it
looks like he's back in business with
this move king b6 which doesn't look too
accurate you guys were talking about b5
I was really worried about that move
that looked like it was cementing the
position the advantages for black and
looking to torture white as much as
possible but this King on b6 looks a bit
more exposed and looked like it would be
passive on the d7 square and an extra
piece if
marches of the board but in fact it
could be a target to a night landing on
c3 it could never really take on before
because a rook will show up on the
beeline and so now he's getting some
dynamic chances to defend its Fabi
I think this move King b6 is gonna be
one that Magnus kicks himself about as
this position may be solidifying is
gonna all be about coordination for
white design on b1 so does it enters the
game and he gets coordinated with his
pieces then he's not gonna be worse he's
just gonna be okay boy I feel like I've
got a I've got to make a confession here
because while we were on break and I
went to Jesse and thanked him very much
for subbing for you I said you know you
Jesse you you you kept talking about
this move b5 blockading the pawn on b4
as well as the move rook a - and I have
to confess that I thought King b6 was a
really good move because you're getting
ready to blockade the pawn you've
activated the King and I thought that
was a really good move it looks pretty
it looks very pretty and that Jesse says
yeah yeah but the problem has is it's a
thing of timing you step back with the
bishop which gives your this opportunity
to bring your night out and you've also
got this bishop coming to e3 with check
with yeah it's a timing thing and King
b6 is not as precise as b5 and the next
corner for that that outpost looks
really dazzling so and the way he
explained it to me it cleared up all the
cobwebs and I said thank you and then of
course King b6 is played it was like oh
I mean that's the story of the match
from games two to five that one player
gets a little something-something and
then a hesitate adversary usually just
defends brilliantly
I think game one was game one was the
exception to that story arc that he
needed help so far it feels like for two
to five we're getting a similar arc of
phenomenal defense Maurice I think
you're overstating the phenomenal
defense defense for these guys because
truthfully there have it seems as though
they're not in precise form I
the great defense that has been coming
you can have all the great defense you
want if your worse your worse and if the
guy plays the right moves for example
and it's been retreating moves to by the
way that point you made Jen this move
with Fabi when he missed the idea and
wasn't it a Bishop d2 miss actually it
wasn't it was also a five right he could
have played rook takes a five instead of
Bishop to d2 he could have played rook
takes a five in Game two and then play
Bishop d2 he admitted after he actually
played Bishop d2 itself that he missed
the retreating move rook to a8 in this
game
Magnus could have played squeeze moves
like b5 but here comes the retreating
Bishop d2 would he have suspected that
the bishop would have gone back to d2 in
this position of retreating move to give
way for the knight to go forward and now
the variations are gonna start working
in White's favor as this helps him to
coordinate his pieces are obviously this
Bishop is not well placed here and it's
gonna be better placed here as is out of
the way of the night and c3 is such a
beautiful square for the knight as
opposed to the circuit of d2 and trying
to figure out where you're gonna go from
there especially when that part was on
b5 and stopping the knight from going
anywhere so this will Bishop d2 if we
start looking at it concretely there's
one variation we have to note and it's
this one rook over check and now King up
the board and here's the problem it
looks like black is getting everything
all the activity but suddenly Knight c3
check you grab your pawn and now you're
hitting the night and you're hitting
this pawn on d3 but white can play
directly just start changing off and he
got his bad piece that the piece that
Jesse was talking about with the bad
piece it's now gone the good bishop also
gone after pawn takes rook takes now
play this rook me one check white has
active pieces suddenly well let's be
aggressive King here rook takes and for
a moment it is black who's up material
one pawn up threatening a mate maybe
he's the one who was doing something but
a move like King F 1 for example now
that he's perfectly fine is white and
guess who's on the seventh rank and
acting crazy on that rank is this rook
the pawn said the bishop said the pawns
gonna be hit all your initiative has
dried up he's gotten rid of all the bad
pieces and also your primary good piece
that bishop on e6 and suddenly he's back
in business and
white should be more than okay here so
Magnus no doubt missed this retreating
move Bishop d2 all the way back here
this move this is the kind of move that
top grandmasters will miss regularly
retreating moves or one of them moves
where you can go to a square that's
protected by pieces or most especially
by a pawn and other type moves like
discovered attacks we talked about that
as well these are kind of moves at the
top top player is minutes they don't
miss things like pins and forks and
that's boring stuff for them but the top
players will miss these subtle kind of
moves that play with the mind in a
retreating move is one of them and I
think Magnus miss Bishop d2 and now you
see him stuck on the position because if
he had seen Bishop d2 he would have
moved already right now that he's
looking at he's like where's my vantage
go and it looks like Fabi is back in
business
because you know you talked about Grand
Master lose at Miss but it's even more
difficult to see a move that is your
opponent's idea as opposed to your own
right because in both of those cases
with missing Bishop d2 and rotate right
it wasn't like Magnuson FOB you missed
the opportunity when it was in their
hand mm-hmm they missed the response of
their opponent which shows that even the
most elite players can fall into the
trap that Marie so eloquently described
in The Trevor Noah show it's exactly
what he asked you up in your own right
exactly what he asked me he said was the
most important thing you've learned from
chess or one of the most important
things and I mention that on the show
that you're not as important as your
opponent you're not the other person is
more important than you are because you
know your own ideas you've got them you
want to defend them you want to prove
them sure great for you but the other
person is coming with their ideas as
well and you have to play both sides if
I do this what is the other person going
to do what's the best idea they're gonna
come up with and if you don't seek out
their best ideas you'll just miss the
moves because you're off in la-la land
thinking about your great stuff you want
to do and that's the hardest part about
chess is always and consistently playing
for your opponent the best moves that
they could possibly play and in that
case for example and probably play
Bishop d2 against Magnus he did not seek
out well what would I do in this
situation what would be the most
desperate thing
for black to do here he only saw a rook
takes a one and oh yeah I get my party
rolling this is good then rook a it
comes and he's like Oh
oh yeah right what's that about and it's
not a hard move to find so that just
shows how much he was into himself and
we're seeing that happen here as well
magnets not seeking out every
possibility that white could play to
coordinate his position and this move
Bishop d2 has got him and he has played
the move rook to d8 going down into this
line probably thinks this is good but it
looks as though great defense now will
hold this position for white and she
knows I love so much about chess that
these principles like for a
kindergartener they miss a background
check because they're not looking at
their opponent's ideas but the same
exact underlying principle applies at
the very highest level in the world
championship in London absolutely
well I remember of course the book by
admire madness how to beat Bobby Fischer
and Adam are looked at every loss that
Bobby Fischer had and the why did Bobby
Fischer ever losing chess game well the
90% of the games that Bobby Fischer lost
is because he wasn't considering what
his opponent was doing he was only
looking at his ideas that was the bottom
line how do you feel like a rewrite of
that based on Magnus Carlsen would look
quite similar I think a lot of times
Magnus loses a games
is he's over press like papiano himself
has won some games against Magnus where
fabbi was trying to make a draw and
Magnus kept going going going going then
he went over over the limit so to speak
there was one game where he's just gone
up and lost did Magnus
so yeah you get caught up in what you're
doing you don't really pay attention any
opponent I wanted to say Maurice about
the variation that you showed after the
move rook d8 which was Magnus's move I
thought if I was in in fabbi shoes I
wasn't looking so much at Bishop e3 is I
was desperate to play Knight c3 and in
my mind the variation I had in mind was
rook takes d3 what else Knight check
Knight Chateau checks oh pardon me
Knight a four check Knight a four check
and I thought well if you move up with
your King King b5 then I got this cute
move Knight see
five attacking the rook but it also
attacks the pawn on b7 and I thought for
example rook a three night b7 White was
out of the woods I mean a moment ago I
was much worse now I feel like okay I
got no no worries
it's a good line as well oh it's a good
line what happens when the knight
appears into the game that that why can
a service for this kind of play very
quickly black's pieces still remain
active however and of course the the
thing is this King looks aggressive
looks aggressive from where it is I
would say this Knight does leave a weird
impression yeah as it's something like
like this shove back for example scares
oh I'm gonna return the pond I'm gonna
play Knight c5 you know I'm not gonna
try to save the bond that said this this
shows what happens as soon as the knight
is released from prison exactly that
Bishop d2 move says we're getting into
the game come hell or high water this is
what's gonna happen right once that
happens then your king dominance doesn't
prove anything and what's happening also
as well we should point out is the
shrinkage of the board when the board
starts to shrink dramatically there's
nothing extra on this side then there's
less to play for even if I were to lose
upon there's less to play because the
fight it becomes a four file game it
becomes all about this and all this
doesn't matter because the pawns have
been removed from the board you always
want to have at least one pawn on both
sides of the board if you're trying to
win because it just becomes that much
harder to win when you reduce the board
and the player only has to defend that
small space more contained if you can
stretch the defense by putting a pawn on
this side then not only of the defend
one weakness over here you got to defend
over here and it's too much to do you
stretch him out
but in this case you remove all his
pawns from this side I remember watching
I remember the first time I saw this
happen this kind of defense happened i
watch gata Kamsky do it in blitz in the
world open I would say sometime in the
early 90s Wow
get a blitz game okay and he was young
man he was super young right and he
played this blitz game it was a playoff
game against someone I don't remember I
just remember what he did and so quickly
the game that he played he so fast
understood the idea of removing
the point and the way he did it too was
just so magical that when he got to
removing it I said honey so just know
that he needed to do that so quickly and
when he got there it just it opened up
my eyes to this type of defensive idea
and here you see it happening of course
it's basic for these guys the idea of
removing anything on that side both
variations your variation taking 97
another variation with Ruby 1 and rook
takes p7 well them are aimed at getting
rid of this one culprit gone on v7
that's the most important point on the
board by far for black and he needs it
he needs it somehow jesse had mentioned
you know 20 moves from now you could
Queen this pawn but if I don't give you
to have that problems off the board at
all costs then even if I have to
sacrifice upon even those kind of
positions will be draw if I lose upon
and get rid of this one and then limit
you to just these four pawns on this
side of course I'd want also the right
distribution of pieces don't want to be
left with the wrong thing right Bishop
versus Knight kind of thing that may be
a problem but this position is looking
more and more like Christmas or Fabi
come early or Thanksgiving anyway means
you draw sorry Jennifer I've kind of
lost touch a little bit with the players
what are the what are the clock times
for both players anybody taking too much
time because no they're broken people
have plenty of time considering that
there's a there were so many moves that
were prepared so they both have about 40
minutes nice moves which you know in
addition to that there's a 30 second
increment it's way too early to accuse
anybody of course it's always possible
right yeah I haven't really been paying
attention as to how long that be is for
example right here they had a hundred
percent prepared the more ambiguous
thing was how much did magnets have
prepared how fuzzy was it was coming up
with it on his own was he rehashing old
files even perhaps bluffing a bit but he
didn't know it in order to you know
unveil the really good lines that's the
kind of thing that is always really
interesting how deep well for you how
deep was the preparation like I mean it
seemed to me fabbi played this move
Queen to
move that Jessie queried by the way but
he played it rather quickly followed by
Queen seafood Oh totally instantly yeah
Quincy for which also looks a little bit
fuzzy like that that especially was a
strange move for me and and how deep did
he did he prepare because at a certain
moment you stop and say okay I like my
position that when he did stop it seemed
that black was fine and we do have the
eight on the board we do and we've been
waiting for
fabbi to make that make the
determination of either Bishop III check
or the move I had expected Knight c3 and
I guess he's trying to way which one of
those two alternatives is the best I I
would be anxious to bring my night on be
one that's been laggard it hasn't gotten
in the game the idea of jumping that the
c5 square is so attractive I would be
inclined to nicely three by the way just
to point out boldly point out the
obvious 93 do not take this pawned that
would be a huge mistake because after
the move rook a b1 pinning the knight to
the Queen you did it right to the king
you don't want to walk into any any pins
for check once again and the bishop and
the rook
so either way yeah don't don't be
thinking about taking III don't leave my
pawns I'm free for nothing no no you can
take the one on d3 but don't take the
one on before and once again Maurice you
you can help me determine which is the I
don't know if King b5 is the right move
by the way this looks like whites out of
the woods
it doesn't matter another nine a four
check the fight that you're nice landing
on c5 by fours or takes the three rook
takes t3 they're just like if you go
back with the King I'm going tonight c5
and on any on any move you're guarding
also the b3 so
we're so there's no rugby 3 to harass
you in any way shape or form there's no
verb to be 3 I am attacking the rook
like if Christians watching now he's not
as though I mean just go back look at
this mess
I'm taking that pretty piece and we'll
take a picture of this position in our
minds no go forward ok sorry I just want
to the audience take a picture with that
King on c7 yes please and the knight on
c5 yeah I'll take a picture of that
position Pierce is the one that's on our
board right now I want you to leave that
one up for a second I will just leave
that one out for a second right so you
got that one look at that 9 on c5 it's
Thor right look at that King on c7 now I
want to go back to a position look up my
board we're gonna go now to my board
yeah leave that one now look the Kings
on c7 we have the pieces the same
difference we have now is a rook on d3
that diagram I just showed you right and
the knight on c5 right right well the
bishop is back on d2 or it's cool so
that's the small that's a small
difference a gigantic difference
how did that happen in just a couple of
moves you get a knight here and a rook
here but this rook that's not doing
anything and this night that was the bad
piece is a monster on c5 that's the
difference right so we could we could
jockey back and forth I'm at Frank let
me play let me play mmm let me play
another move instead this move let's get
let's get this one everybody you had
King b6 on the board yes I know I'm
sorry I'm trying to get the position I'm
just gonna make look how many Tempe I
gained by the way I'm gonna make some
random move and then play it like this
okay this is the this is similar right
I'm gonna put the bishop back this is
similar this is losing the rook on but
let's leave this position now go from
this position and make the point switch
back to your board yeah like remember
this board I switch back the same same
thing virtually I got a pawn in 86 in
mine right that's the only difference
I got a pawn in 86 but look what our
Knight has done it's magically
transformed itself to the c5 square it's
a beast it's happy and so this is not
acceptable for Magnus in any way shape
or form
this means Fabi has solved the problem
so 93 I really like Bishop e3 is more
forcing but 93 also begs all the
questions I got my night out and what
can you do about it looks like nothing
that that night on b1 was in the
barracks just waiting it to get into the
battle and in the scenario that I've got
on my board with that Knight on
see five suddenly going from doing
absolutely nothing on be ones in the
basement yeah it was locked in the
basement of being this great piece now
he's raising on green pastures whole
difference it's all the difference in
the world and any disadvantages are now
comfortably behind that one came Bobby
exactly it's pulling its weight it's
funny because as soon as Jesse cry God
he was he was bemoaning that night for
the hour in between the opening stage
and Maurice filling in for him he was
crying about that night why can we use
so many violent crimes right why
couldn't we invite him back to the show
now that he has something to talk about
yeah dealing with the bad pieces as we
know bad pieces one bad piece can spoil
an entire chest position and you want to
improve your horrible pieces you don't
want to try to be active without the
whole army coming into play certainly we
work as a team through the chess pieces
there's so many principles that we could
talk about when I mentioned Trevor Noah
had asked me that important question
about what do you learn from chess and
that's another one of those great
principles I have to say though I really
want to promote his book more than ever
born a crime is a book you absolutely
want to buy in heat look at this
autograph that he wrote in the book that
I gave to visit to Maurice make all your
children be legal that was a bit of
referring to his own experience and
apartheid South Africa yes indeed he was
born in criminal born a crime in born a
criminal indeed it's family his family
had been the one ones who we get
arrested because of his mace he was
mixed race and his mother was a black
horse a woman and his father a swiss
german and they were not allowed to mix
back in 80's the eight 1980s
South Africa before Mandela was released
and there was literally five years in
prison
for mixing five years in prison if you
were caught mixing with the races and
the father had to walk across the street
when they went outside the father had to
walk across the street his father had to
walk across the street from the family
and his mother had to hire a fully
colored woman a mixed woman to walk with
him it higher as the nanny but actually
pretend that she the black woman was the
nanny while the woman she hired was the
mother so that they would the people
would believe that
okay that's his mom the one who was
mixed and the other one is a nanny
because she's not supposed to she
couldn't possibly be the mother of this
boy this makes the boy
that I mean an incredible so now I'm
saying that that sounds quite sad but
the rest of the book is hilarious the
guy's a comedian after all and it is so
fun and funny to read when I gave it to
my mom to read she had visited me a back
in June mm-hmm all I heard in the room
was go fine I went in there you all
right she said he's crazy
it's such a fun funny book definitely
worth the read I can I can I'll give you
a refund if you don't like this book or
or I got a first check your you know
your psychological profile if you don't
like this book at you buy it is such a
good book to read you sold me Maurice
and I have a dad and Trevor and what I
like about that inscription is it kind
of reminds me of his style which is very
funny but there's like an important be
hot point behind the humor
you know that we always got to be
watchful about our current you know your
current situation and making sure that
there's not injustice and that we're
attacking it when it's there so
beautiful job in the show and beautiful
inscription yes by Trevor Noah who i i'm
sure you've converted the chasse yeah
he's on t Bobby right I actually didn't
have to convert to Jesse yeah he does
play that in the clip that you can find
online right now but he loves chess
already he was serious he played chess
in high school and he really enjoys it
he just you know he just had to make fun
of it for the daily show when he
actually been in front of it when John
Stehr
was the host of the day he came on as a
senior correspondent so it was it was
what it was it's pretty funny that clip
is funny too by the way I'm making fun
of chess but you know I had to bust his
chops come of course in Jamaica in front
of our game like that by the way this is
good for Abby has made the more I would
say forceful move there's both street
checkers on the board at 93 you know
I've been so anxious to bring that night
who they gave I couldn't wait for the
happen play 93 hold your horse yeah that
well indeed
but fabbi did play Bishop III Shaq and
Maurice you gave a variation that went
with the King to b5 right that turned
out to be nothing
what about if Magnus dropped back with
how ridiculous would that be though you
just well you just played King b6 I know
you let me play Bishop d2 am Bishop III
thank you very much
I lost three moves to and the rooks not
better on d8 than it was on a eight so
but okay I'm taking I mean sometimes you
make a mistake you gotta take but now
what if I play rook C 1 given you can't
just give people free moves right so
once C let me threaten d5 threatens b4
b5 and you're forcing me to move my King
yet again pointing out but if b5 happens
now opens dead yeah then now we can play
Knight c3 and smile yeah because now
you're tickling my pawn which is why I
had to drop boy talk about wasting talk
a lot of energy a lot of time wasting
went on in that line I mean there's no
way you're gonna feel badly if you're
well at the moment I'm still I'm still
recovering a pawn right because there
are two white pawns hanging and even
though white is upon ahead
the Knights still on b1 so well how
would the line continue from these parts
I'm just checking variations now would
it be five yeah okay that does of course
I get the attacks the night the night
was about to Clark capture the pawn so
you returned the favor
so what do you feel about this position
it does
I don't know at the moment I don't feel
that this is as equal as a moment ago I
had the night on c5 and I was kind of
feeling good about myself here
maybe the jury's out I unless there's
some really cute move like d4 perhaps
where yeah where maybe you know like the
king for whatever reasons finds itself
you still need to get the knight out to
cause me oh you you're saying Bishop c7
but you still need to get the night out
too well I need to play okay what you
know so in this position night II one
okay so night Edgar one right now the
retreating he has another heart is fine
retreating them so now this brother
still 93 there's a rookie one Knight
takes D 3 there is rook d1 and we
continue the variation there's still
Bishop c4 93 and then now you're
desperate actually you have to play
Bishop a - it looks like a bishop a -
tactically saving the day yeah okay but
I don't have to you're gonna have to
give up all your good pieces at that
point Knight ac3 Bishop takes p3 Brooke
b1 that's not the variation that I was
really aiming for when I when I stepped
into this that's funny though cuz 91
does kind of complete the trio speaking
of which the retreating moves rook a8
Bishop d2 and now 91 right and Knight is
supposed to be the even even the most
difficult very high-level moves or
retreating moves and now use your
haven't so retrieved your pawn is yet no
a lot to prove yeah that's
it's a funny variation it's it's it's a
peculiar situation where I can't take on
d3 I guess what should i do should I
make a move I don't know let me just put
them over up d7 on the board so at least
I have a threat my threat is now to
capture the pond I'm just a little
concerned that unless fat begets this
night v1 into the game well I don't know
Maurice this looks like compensation but
is threatening to coming to the game
rook d1 let's just guard the pond what
is happening let's just guard the Bishop
Bishop c4 looks like night a3 is coming
okay Bishop c4 you mentioned as being
met by the move Knight a3 then there is
now going to be a pin whenever I capture
on d3 mmm well okay I don't know what to
say well I know you're a pawn grubber
yes I'm trying no what I'm saying is
White's the one who's up upon oath or
you're playing with compensation there
and I know you're a pawn broker so being
up a pawn I know suits you nicely Ron
and being down upon doesn't and you
can't give that pawn back then you're
only speaking compensation and nothing
more well I was thinking that the punt
compensation was far more clear when
black had played the move b5 and there
was a black rook on the a file oh yeah
that's that's exactly well you're
talking about dropping the King back now
yeah that move Bishop e3 check which is
highlighting this this King swinging
back and forth there is no way the world
champion plays moves like that if he
doesn't have to because he'll be very
aware of the fact that he would have
wasted wasted 16 yeah and he's gonna be
sitting there going really you know what
this other line might be drawing but I'm
not gonna play this bogus line where I
lost two moose I'd be stunned to see
King c7 land on the chess board
Jennifer what did he play after Bishop
e3 what did Magnus do okay okay let me
do that let me update my board I switch
back I'll trade it to the forcing line
oh he did go King there was no way he
was playing King c7 he lost
okay so exist this was this whole
variation that you it showed us quite
some time ago already Maurice that you
mentioned after rug defy one factor Jack
King came to see three in your line rook
takes b7 rook captured here then after
King f1 you're explaining why white was
really really pleased because he has no
ugly pieces there's no Knight on b1
although he's a pawn down that's only
temporary White has a two threats he has
a threat of rook f7 as well as rook c7
attacking this Knight and pinning that
night to the king and that everything
was fine suddenly like just like that
everything had shifted there was no
issues if he does know right except
three your throne a mate so we have to
choose a different object well I like I
like that 95 move because it it
reinforces every threat that white has
including rook c7 which i think is the
one you really gotta be kiddin to
because that by the way to you by the
way 95 is good there now I'm just loving
learning maybe we watch but I'd like to
talk about me King c300 forward please
King oh please yeah Kingston I'd like to
talk about this you know when you when
you watch high level players you want to
learn something from them and looking at
this position here the move
efore was it was it a four and you plane
i g5 right so i do it what about a move
like Knight e4 play right and what about
91 also 91 attacking the rook that's a
devilish tickle just just to realize
since we're now learning about
retreating moves so much this is being
played so often 95 of course is a good
move what's the point out Knight back is
an idea here very good also works as
well but let's change this and go
forward step step into this line back up
back up and in this moment after
go back just a couple of moves to work
d5 this moment this moment here oh yeah
the move Knight d8 that's good cuz that
after.look c7 check we can take with the
King exactly
another moment that's the right move
order guarding the pawn on f7 and the D
part is dropping now legitimately so
that's a good move by Magnus mmm did you
get blade did it I know there's still oh
they're almost there so you wait 27 next
it's very easy to imagine that probably
overlook this move whoa
look III I'm a pawn grabber in the
family over here we only have a room on
Sept 4 but that king on d3 could get
checkmate it easily could an e4 allows
the retreating move but 31 mates so
incredible how knight retreats Bishop
retreats they're popping up constantly
in this game the retreating game if you
will variation is just absolutely
incredible so this is very very very
doubtful but if you don't do it by the
way there is there are still okay this
is not a mate but you're gonna end up
being forced to sacrifice a rug wait why
why they're making at five oh shoot more
retirement I apologize so wait so wait
after age six oh well I don't know of
age six is the best move I I wish to I'm
Mike G for ig4 looks so sneaky
so really 91 in Brooksie for winning yes
yeah
same as same principle I'm also
threatening 91 King e4 key to running a
free mate correct so even though black
isn't one upon up there's some tactical
issue here you have 92 I've like ideas
every night
one and work takes me something was
played it looks like okay we're gonna
see that so we're on expect now okay so
hard so hold on so this is the current
position we've just seen rook takes b7
here we're expecting this very very
sneaky
retreat he moved 98 which side steps
this pinning sequence that began with
rook c7 defends the pawn on f7 right
well we're we're saying that's possible
but I'm not telling you never 9 possible
you think it's probable sure the king on
d3 you think male I'm not saying that
King takes d3 is but I'm saying okay
hold on what do you think blacks best
move is then I think Knight d8 is
probably blacks best move right now even
the best move you're saying like don't
play rugby three right away because
because rook takes d3 King f1 and even
though black is a pawn up white is
getting it right back
King f1 wait is night what happens on 98
here it's bad because of I don't know
just like a 98 you could do that for
sure Shadow King has to find a square
right and then maybe Knight g5 Knight g5
could be happening in kini to happen as
well the 9 g5 looks King e2 is on tap
well I mean if I was on f7 why it's not
worth it on white White's for choi yeah
white for choice so exactly here but if
you're saying 98 let's go 98 royal c7
check if you have to play King takes if
you have to play King takes on d3 and
allow King f1 then there's a lot of
complicated variations you got to
calculate this black and black is
clearly not winning yeah me forget about
the pawn up like it's not winning but
maybe he won't choose the 98 line we did
we have to do that that's what I'm
saying yeah if you're okay just white
how does black get out of this okay
let's see but it's your pickle eyes okay
so I'm just gonna stop Knight g5 and say
go ahead complete your threat g4g
- g4 okay man oh man okay
my clock is ticking I gotta make a move
quickly knocking [ __ ] you're opening the
d5 square for your king I'm trying I'm
trying to zag my way home yeah you're
like you ninety-one check and rook c5 or
maybe rook c5 first Knight e1 check and
rook c5
so you're still well I'm sorry that was
a mouse slip of course so you're still
trying to set up a check maybe well sure
I mean like King e2 and f3 to do what I
want I think I've got all right so what
do I need to do no let's go in that line
it looks reasonable 91 check King e4
okay I am I am trying to to slalom my
way I also had the idea of g5 at some
point menu bishop go back but where does
my knight belong in this line well let's
see this is this is basically the key
moments right here
I liked and I think it was late by the
way which was play 98 one the board as
we might see some pretty exciting very
ancient wow this is the current position
and we're expecting rook c7 check King
takes d3 by Magnus giving them upon edge
but we're thinking King F 1 + 3 results
possible listen this is a board
qualifiable ok my side and sensitive as
far as the pawns are concerned if I'm
white I'm feeling like I'm very close to
a draw very absolutely like this is not
a losing position we now have a
situation with this this position where
there's four point we're looking at
concrete lines we're looking at mating
attacks could we actually win but white
can also be very realistic and say wait
a second what is your winning plan how
does black actually proceed to win this
game like what is he's got to get his
King back this thing is probably got to
be here you're right
right oh yeah target sent treating yeah
that's probably what he needs to do
right and he has to start there so you
can start bringing is nine into the game
now even with all that that means he has
to play something like eight six because
we're gonna Knight g5 when that happens
so even with all those multiple moves
that you've got to play even then what's
your winning plan because you still have
four against three your passport is this
one right potentially right and you're
not necessarily tying me down I'm very
active right now so I don't feel I just
don't feel like I'm gonna lose this game
oh the picture is not there for another
20 moves I agree going to make this four
against three work he's got to deal with
all the rank issues and I've done
nothing I'm just named everything he has
to do and me not defending at all and
you first of all it's even though a
question with a nut you could get your
night yeah you're king all the way back
home because I'm gonna try to keep it
where it is and if I get a move like
this in this plot formation becomes
salta fide on the on the other on this
side for a long time to come
that's not going to be easy for you to
make any advances with a pawn sitting on
this square of course it's probably
become a weakness as well but this is
not feeling like a loss anymore I mean
this is feels like White has full
compensation for the sacrifice with a
knight sitting back on d8 now it's
surprising Fabi is thinking right now
that's a bit of a surprise to me after
the move Knight D and it may suggest
that he missed ninety eight when he wins
this position maybe maybe not maybe
we're overstating this retreating
concept of missing backward moves but it
the fact that we don't have a move right
now and it works III looks weird c7
excuse me looks like the only move with
the King on c3 giving a check may
suggest as we're in this position that
he didn't see the move nevertheless
positional principles say this is fine
for white I mean no way white should be
worse here or worried about being or
worried about losing let's put it that
way worried about losing and Magnus will
have to be careful about the little
dance he mates that that are being
looked at although I don't think he's
gonna fall for any of them oh no I don't
see any dangers either for white
personally I I think that this King on
d3 is is far more of
a target so I so yeah I see this as
three results not that white has to
instantly play for draw with some move
like Knight g5 in order to to restore
material equality with Knight takes f7 I
think that by the way please now I just
look back at the engine to see what
things and you're not gonna believe this
but in the position after King f1 in
this position King f1 eight-six is a
blunder and g4 is better for white the
engines of screaming there g4 and you
better give me back the pawn immediately
with night to e6 because and they're
insisting that h5 is actually the right
move here to stop g4 to stop g4 itself
so we should look at this line after g4
of what other move could we play I mean
let's let's play your Bishop f6 and
notice the engine now by the way we do
have rook c7 and king d3 cyborg replayed
and now [ __ ] oh well that's that's the
line the check King Year King here and
what did you know you did rook these six
before didn't you well yeah and this
position you did this move I was trying
to make room for the king that's right
and now the engine gives Bishop to c5 as
the right whoa
forcing your rook ooh ooh your rook has
a problem okay there's a little file
problem rook c63 check where do you put
this joker well it's already clear right
you have 7 is gonna draw exactly the
mission was gonna leave and if
something's gonna drop you and your
knight is gonna hang exactly you're
gonna start right now you got some real
problems here so already after king f1
Magnus has to be really careful and play
this is not the only move this is the
other move but now why white is just
perfectly fine the activity favors white
Wow well this game is actually giving a
statement after the green trade is that
this game feels like a real real game at
feel good about this you feel good about
it because it's a great game you're both
worried about it for team favi well just
everything about the game from I think
the very courageous decision to play b4
stop this repetition of Bishop takes c6
I think the players were exploring some
real original ground and you know
they've been mixing it up one played by
the way and let's go one more time just
for the fans
efore go for it yes does your little one
recognize checkmate yeah oh yeah
[Music]
checkmate Alva okay tell you I'll tell
you what I really the point you guys
made is so important it's wonderful to
watch players of this caliber play it's
like when you watch the computers play
in those those tournaments that they
have the world the world leader
championship championships and they do
stuff and you're like what's that about
yeah what's that about it once and some
of it is so cryptic that you you can't
understand if a 15 moves why they made a
move right and it's night you learn as
you watch you learn as you watch these
top-level games and when you watch a
game like this one now you're not going
to produce this kind of struggle every
single game unfortunately but or maybe
they'll they'll coast and finally
they're in form and they'll both start
playing these 28 30 28 50 level chess
but when you get to watch it and go oh
look at that idea oh look at that idea
this is what the people who love
classical chess
love the most is the ability to sit down
and really sink into a game and look at
the ideas deeply and appreciate point by
point players like a fans like myself
who really would love to look forward to
seeing more rapid time controls more
tournaments like that being played don't
want to kill this kind of tournament
this kind of event where you can also
enjoy the juiciness you can look and you
can learn you can
analyze these nuances and they're
playing like solid 2800 right now
high-level chess yeah I stock up on here
psych up on there
I stocked up on first you sack it back
you got comp is it a mate Oh watch out
cuz I got these new ideas just simply
good stuff to appreciate at this high
level I don't know about 2,700 I bet you
the cap score on this game is off the
charts yeah I feel like it's a $20
Bureau would say you could observe a lot
just by watching by the way I want to
make this point and I really fat eclis
fabbi is the one who's playing like the
highest rated player in the world and
Magnus is playing like he's the second
highest rated player in the world really
yeah do you see the teepee ours are the
players
thank you finally my humor is being
appreciated Yaris tournament performance
rating by the way and of course he is
totally the mirrors because he's drawing
against the higher rate another example
of how I'm biased we are here okay let's
go to break ass but let's keep that
position after E for 91 on the screen
thank you for joining us today in chess
show we have demonstrated that there is
a checkmate in the position away from
checkmate
I'm Abby you can do it you can do it and
there are a few variations like that
movie Noah Magnus is gonna dig deep and
look for the best defense we're gonna be
back with more from what's turning out
to be a very exciting endgame in
Carolina Carlsen
[Music]
may have heard about st. Louis's
world-class museums art history science
even magic
[Music]
but you may not know we have an entire
museum dedicated to play with a 10-story
slide and a ferris wheel on top don't
let all this family fun slide by you
[Music]
whose kids it is st. Loup is always
exploring anybody st. Louis University
celebrating its 200th anniversary
offering world-class education in the
heart of st. Louis Slough attracts
students and professors from around the
globe in 2015
SLU partner with the same Lewis Chess
Club to start a top tiered collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
team's inception Slough obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose greater good st. Louis
University
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello and we are back and Game five of
the World Chess Championship between
Fabiano Khurana and Magnus Carlsen has
again
beaten drawn as we sold like actually
just like an incredibly well played game
yes absolutely when we went to break
seriously I bring encounter defense by
Fabi all the way down the line when we
went to break we saw this position King
f1 Maryse and I we had been discussing
and Maryse was mentioning there's
absolutely one crucial move that black
has to play did magnify yes he did he
played this a very very important move
h5 and just when we were on break all of
these very again high precision moves
were all just made one after the other
after the other and sometimes Maryse you
just sit back and tip your hat and say
dude you played really well this was
just a great game to do did you do
respect it to put some respect on their
names exact what we're talking about
right this one as both of them showed
that they are indeed the two best
players in the world
Magnus sniffed out that danger to his
king and said no no no no I'm not
getting mated you must be joking I get
the fact that you have enough Karen to
play in this position to easily
counterbalance that pawn edge that I had
and so he just quickly flung his king
back home safe no dangers and of course
he had to give back upon in order to do
that in that position in in the drawer
so this to me I mean it's got to say
you've got to be saying if you are Fabi
I'm with this guy I'm with this guy I
mean of course attention is building but
Fabi said to have some confidence that I
can hate I mean clearly we've drawn the
majority of our games are we continue to
draw I am indeed equal to you at least
you remember Fabi before this match he
said point blank I think it's a 50/50
I think it's 50/50 I'll and it was penny
anybody who said Magnus in a walk
cakewalk Magnus is much stronger you're
a fobby fan probably it was very
objective he said I think it's 5050
right and it's gonna come down to the
nerves
now as this bills some of you might say
we need a win but to me from a friend of
mine we have a shout out to Kim smooth
because she said this is like the
Powerball okay nobody's winning the putt
the tensions rising and someday
somebody's gonna win right and it's
gonna be a big deal when that person
wins so this is like the Powerball it is
increasing in tension game by game by
game and who has the nerves to win in
this what could come down to a lottery
situation because right now we don't
know what's gonna happen but somebody's
gonna score eventually but this was one
of my favorite games in the mat because
what you're seeing is you're seeing
humans achieve perfection I mean they're
like they're coming so close to just
becoming like perfect and it's so it
looks so easy when you watch but the
amount of preparation and life planning
that goes into being able to be an
example of perfection at the more twenty
good moves in a row good moves are oh
but what goes behind those 20 moves in a
row is twenty years of dedication to the
ground
absolutely like in every way physically
mentally preparation travel in the case
of Fabi
this moving to Europe where there are
great tournaments moving back to live in
st. Louis when this emerged as the
capital of chess in America just like
everything was scripted great great
they're great parents on your side
support rate family everything
everything ever that this is the ideal
conditions for creating chess automatons
so we're looking at now these two are
playing like machines which is an
argument people have a lot chess by the
way maybe it's their getting so good
what did we see in Norway chess so many
draws very few wins we saw the
Sinquefield Cup even less wins
I hate to say it but it's what happened
now we're seeing in this man
a lot of drawers the top players don't
lose so easily very very difficult to
defeat each other and we have these two
super duper grandmasters at work and
it's just hard to land a punch yeah this
chance in game 1 for the knockdown
I come from a fight family my sister a
world champion boxer my brother a world
champion kickboxer actually five titles
for my sister two for my brother and one
thing I learned from them you don't want
to be knocked down you don't wanna be
the first to go hit that floor and
that's what we're seeing right now guys
looking at each other ducking and
dodging bobbin and Weavin
he missed the punch the chance in the
brown one but now four rounds later
they're just showing they're looking at
each other maneuvering for weakness
going all out but both sides throwing
they know how to duck and dodge and not
get hit and this is this is good stuff
right here at a high level the fans
might not like you because they want a
victory the casual fan but as you
mentioned Jen for the ones who like
pristine play and amazing technique this
is the good stuff I can see you are the
underachiever in the family the black
sheep their piece you're gonna have to
do better than just become an
international Grandmaster you know comes
around you're just keeping a low profile
aren't you over there my friend Trevor
Noah period so I got that on them for
now okay very good
that was a good your biceps Marius
that's got to feel good everything you
were saying Jen I can concur a hundred
percent with I mean this was a great
game I mean again for for the chess
purist were in our element this was
great play by both players they made it
look easy but they had some really
awkward and difficult decisions both
players had to make and the fact that we
stand deadlocked after five bodes for a
great match and I always thought it was
a great match those people that kept
predicting Magnus's the victor were
really giving him the
because of the tiebreaks right daddy's
reality by the way the people will give
him the edge because of the tiebreak
still give him the edge because it's
Highbury so they're saying keep this up
and see what happens
right it may be that a volcanic eruption
is going to happen and we get winds all
over the place no I mean in terms in
terms of Fabi that he's actually setting
the seeds of this volcanic eruption on
himself because yeah you you're taught
you keep tying and keep drawing keep
drawing you keep drawing and the
pressures building in the pressures
building and so did you get to game 12
and it's still tied and Magnus goes oh
baby now I'm going to show you where I'm
much stronger than you are and that
might be a problem for Fabi if you argue
that classical the classical portion
will be tied and continues to be tied
there's a long way to go before then but
how do you feel if the next seven games
are drawn as well well he could have
fantastic games but but then what to
give a contrary viewpoint as Yaser said
at the beginning I I think that a lot of
team Fabi fans have things to be happy
about like the fact that he got through
those first few round dinner that's
right so I think perhaps it's a wash
like if you thought that the mat
whatever you thought the match was in
terms of odds going into it elevate a
little bit after yeah not for the
tiebreak people folks know those guys
those guys if you ask Nakamura for
example sure straight up like are you
gonna change your mind now he's going
I'm actually happier now no you're
you're affirming what I said that it's
not about this part it's 5050 this part
what I believe is that the rapid games
and the blitz games are gonna be
crushing in Magnus's face I don't think
I said that so the people not could say
I was rooting for no no we know when he
was interviewed by you yeah
yeah I had him in the chair and he said
it more than once as a matter of fact he
says the the victor is gonna be Magnus
big time 80% because of rapid and blitz
and so anybody who believes that thinks
this is great what's happening for
Magnus this is fantastic
and Magnus can just sit back and say
okay well I'll keep trying for the win
but if it comes to it we're gonna get to
wrap it up listen when they have for
rapid games you're not beating me in for
rapid games so I think that is a danger
to think about now if your father you
can't be lacking in confidence in those
rapid games you've got to think I don't
care if we go to rapid I'm still gonna
get you there two or I might get you
there well that was one very interesting
thing Maurice in the interview with
Grandmaster Christian korilla that I
wasn't really expecting because Fabi had
such a a standout year of so many
classical tournaments I always thought
like the Blitz and rapids they might not
be as memorable but he said the big
confidence boost was not all of his
victories for instance Norway was
actually that exhibition match against
Grisha where he was that was a
confidence boost because he was
considered the underdog and that match
played legend Grisha and he got it done
and remember that was zero increment
zero delay so that's where you would say
somebody like Grisha would have the
biggest edge right so Christian just
says Fabi super confident and that it
all started here in st. Louis with that
victory not bad you know what you know
what [ __ ] you know what Magnus is
confidence booster is that's winning
every rapid Ember one in the world for
take a rapid I'm talking rapid in blitz
come on he's the world blitz champion
right now right he missed out on
becoming the world rapid champion is
Robbie sorry I'm nan had a fantastic
event and when I got comes in second in
any of those events he's like what yeah
how dare you come ahead of me right
that's what his con his confidence has
been built up over years and years and
years of wrapping him blitz so let's
we're all hopeful for Fabi right we're
definitely rooting and we're hoping
you'll be able to fight back but be very
clear Magnus is the best rapido Bliss
player on the planet bar none
no question he's awesome so Bobby yes
playing well right now improving is
equal at the moment in classical chess
and may prove it in the next seven games
but that rapid implicit gonna be
advantage Magnus no matter what and we
will tell the story as an upset if Bobby
beats him in rapido blitz it will be an
upset it won't be like oh yeah that was
a normal thing to happen yeah Maurice
but to state the obvious we've got the
gauntlet now for team Fabia Fabi gets
through this that'll be awesome because
when I came six and seven exactly you'll
have two nights for Magnus that's right
act back and it's a very sweet situation
with fought for Fabi if he does get
through that because remember he's
ending the tournament with Hawaii ends
the match with the white so this is like
the go time for Magnus and he'd be the
first one to really get something with
white because nobody has done it so far
it's get more than a little something
well one thing I really did want to pull
back on and just a shout out to our
audience we are really living in a
golden age of chess right here right now
we've got the world championship match
going on in London got the Women's World
Championship going on in Russia
we've just had this fantastic Shenzhen
tournament we've had a world champion
from illinois's the rods generalise and
here in st. Louis here at the st. Louis
chess club we've just finished our
winter classics these were 210 player
tournaments and let's take a look at the
finals of Group A Jennifer well what a
star-studded field yes not these
grandmasters the whole field is
grandmasters casada Perez
congratulations we need in this field by
two points that's huge look at some of
these names Geoffrey Zhong who was the
star of the Isle of Man really gaining
lots of rating points and stunning us
right after Samuel said Yahoo by the way
got his grand there yeah yeah but who
got his Grandmaster title here in st.
Louis at the Chess Club both these young
men were buoyed in 2000 and that means
they're only 8 years old ok
so Sam and Jeffrey and then we see ray
Robson in the field an Olympic Olympic
gold medal team member and silver member
just a fantastic field congratulations
and meanwhile in the B group another
time player round-robin addressee I am
and that and Nicolas keys and they
actually tied for first and this is unit
five and a half but was I've been
seeking the truth neon Highbury here I
was delighted by the way with Victor I
mean I was saying to him that you know
thank you
he's the real veteran at the field tying
for first let me get back in here let me
talk to Tony rich where's my invite I
want to throw some patties hey hey Colin
big Vic and tomorrow we got the same who
is Invitational the good chest just
doesn't stop yes
November 16th to 21st that's gonna be
210 play around Robbins a $15,000 prize
fun and you can follow it on us stress
champ calm which I'm sure you got
bookmark for the integrity of the world
championship match fine
well now I do I didn't know about this
one I've just well it never stops the
action just never stops by the way I
want to give a big shout out to John
Sonya Abdul Malik who was eliminated
from the round of 8 in the Women's World
Chess Championship she gave such a
performance absolutely brilliant she was
eliminated by Maria Musa choke former
world champion maria Mirza Chucky's who
is currently in the final four but the
tremendous match that was I was so happy
that we actually had the day off I watch
from start to finish they had first of
all it was the first the the first two
games they played then they went to the
rapid him the rapid then they went to
the 10+10 then they went to the the 5+3
and she was eliminated there you could
if you just go over the games you could
not feel the excitement of move by move
as she looked dead in the water only to
come back and then win the game
both times in the different tiebreaks
absolutely brilliant play she's almost
2500 I believe she already has her three
grandmaster norms I expect this young
lady to be a grandmaster anytime soon a
change has the goods we won't be talking
about her much from this tournament on
because she was eliminating the name but
she deserves to get recognition yeah
I'm a fan and Ikes she has played here
before expect more invites because that
girl's a baller she's absolutely
incredible I think one day she will win
the title expect her to be to six if she
keeps up this trajectory
she'll be a 2601 day because she's
absolutely an incredible player but
Marie's not to steal any of your thunder
because I was following the exchange
that you were having with Tony rich
about the that match had it all because
it was a 50 move rule to games yes
goodness and I was watching it and when
the flirt when she when that pawn was
captured on move 86 when it happened it
was a rook and Knight ending rook and
Knight versus rook and when the pawn was
captured on move 86 I made no mental
note move 86 now I don't know what she
was able to do at that point because
she's she's playing a blitz ten plus ten
right so she's in the mix right I don't
know what the rule is there but she got
to a point where she she made such a bad
mistake defending that she was defending
great for a long time and then she got
her King in the corner and all she had
to do is just take her King right out
the corner on the move and she carried
out a couple of checks that allowed the
White King to dance over to set up an
unstoppable mating attack right but
right at that moment she could have it
was matin to coming she could have
stopped the mate she could have played
the one move then the check and then
block with her rook and its mate next
move but when she before she plays rook
back she can say oops that's my fiftieth
move I the game it is drawn I'm claiming
a draw and the ref would have to snap
arbiter had to step in and go yep you've
got your draw before playing Brooke back
allowing rook takes rook mate and one on
the 51st move she didn't realize it she
resigned and lost that game that's how
she lost the match which is just
terrifying to think of that she could
have actually drawn that one as well so
an international arbiter Tony rich
confirmed that yes I check to see
whether or not
that was true yeah it was absolutely
right and that I mean wow epic epic
struggle and again if you go over that
match you will not feel I was thinking
about that in classical chess you really
have to go over it you go over it slowly
you could go over the moves afterwards
people can go over this game we just had
and they could go over it in the leisure
time and just go over the game you can't
do that with rapid in blitz you're gonna
see too many mistakes the computer is
gonna point out there were small
mistakes here and there maybe even big
ones and you don't feel the clock you
don't feel the decision that had to be
made and when person was going down to
two seconds earlier the increment came
back and you don't feel it you only feel
it so rapid a blitz are meant to be
watched
classical chess meant to be studied
while rapid in blitz meant to be watched
and you have to feel that but to watch
those games I mean you're just
incredible
I'm gonna tell you incredible my heart
was in my throat although what again oh
my god oh she's back she's I mean it's
just just absolutely incredible play by
these two great fighters give it up to
Maryam was a joke by the way
for winning that match as well and now
we have three chant world champions one
current and two former in the finals in
the final four just incredible Women's
World Championship going on right now
thank you
earlier in the broadcast the surprise of
the tournament is that all the final
four are favorites
exactly it's such a wild event you
expect a cinderella story and so it
almost were yeah but still you know
plenty of great cast to come for today
in chess including around six of the
World Chess Championship which is going
to kick off Magnus's to whites in a row
so right expect some psychological ploys
some thrilling opening some great
defense that's what we've been seeing in
this match to just all-around great
moves by the two best chess players in
the world but only one can be the
ultimate king and it's getting hot in
here yes absolutely it's been a thrill
calling this game with both of you this
for me was really a great game I really
really enjoyed it I'm looking forward to
Game six tomorrow same time same URL
that's right we're going to be at 9 a.m.
local time here in st. Louis and that's
10 a.m. on the East Coast I'm Jennifer
Shehadeh signing off for Grand Master's
Yasir Sarah Juana Maurice Ashley and a
thank you to our guest Grandmaster
filling in for Maurice uppity Geneva
show Jessi cry absolutely thank you for
joining us everyone
[Music]